I don't even know if you guys can hear the music.
Alright, I'm back, I'm back even though I got back home earlier than I thought I would.
Thank you guys for your understanding, I'm sorry I had to cut the stream I started initially
short but everything's okay now, everything's good, everybody's good and safe and fine,
I need a tweet, cause I always forget to tweet.
Sorry, hey I was watching that, that just killed me a little bit, hey I was watching
that.
So I had Bulldog Ramen the other day, well like yesterday and my asshole was on fire,
I'm sorry I had to tell you, I just thought you'd like to know you know, so I'm sitting
on an ice cube and hoping for the best, hoping that I won't die, it was so delicious though
so worth it, can I fire a napalm, probably, so you can show us your, hey Oshiba you hope
everything is returning to normal so that you can show us your alpha side, and by the
way don't have to postpone if you choose your sentence, I understand, well thank you, it's
okay now, so silly family stuff that honestly has nothing to do with me but I'm just there
to support in case, again my family is fine, I'm fine, I'm trying to get my fucking headphones
on, oh my gosh, this wire is too short, off this satin water, that's what I get for sitting
on an ice cube, these are my bucks cool man, am I allowed to talk about this, this is already
gone, the thing is already demonetized, whatever, we out here having a great time on this lovely
July evening, good morning, good night, good afternoon, I'm your host Shibi, butt is on
firebomb, I should have said Shibi firebomb but it's fine, okay, I'm alive, whoa, oh god
I can hear myself, can you guys hear me, is it an echo, I just wanted to be able to monitor
my sound, I can hear myself and now there's two of me, two of me, two of me, I'm on a tin
can, whoa that's demonetized, I'm cutting this out, I'm cutting this, the VOD's new,
branding the street now, it ain't a Shibi stream without a little scuff, well of course
this is a great game, you guys hear the music, Shibi bottom fire, that's me, this game looks
wild as fuck because you're right, we're in the wild west baby, I'm just kidding I don't
know, I forget what this takes place in Yellowstone, takes place in the wild Midwest baby, I don't
remember, American school system failed me, kinda, okay I'll turn it up to them, oh, how many
cubs do you cook in, we're gonna have so many cubs, again all the cubs, we're cub maxing the
stream, I hate my life, try to think the only thing about these IEMs is that I can't, like it has
a thing where it should let me turn down the volume with them but it's not letting me do that so
I'm just gonna take one ear out, otherwise I can't hear anything, cub maxing, better call Icy, oh my
god, alright, zitter, let's me tweet, honestly I almost don't feel like tweeting because I'm like if
you know you know, if you know you know, okay we back, I don't know if I could put a link in a
quote tweet but Twitter algorithm is fucking weird as hell, and earlier, we're back earlier,
yeah I initially said six but I realized I was gonna be back sooner, please let me retweet my own
post, thank you, oh my god, okay, so the game might be a little bit laggy because this in my
model just don't play nice, well Quest is kind of notorious for that, it's like one of those games
it just like takes up way too much power than it actually needs to be because it's like a decade
old and it doesn't make any sense, is this considered a retro game, oh god, that just makes me feel bad
furry, shut up Nori, shut up, I love you though, that's my girl Noriko
she probably hates being pointed out now, she doesn't know that I gave her mod
when she wasn't around
she's drawing some very beautiful art of me, am I okay, oh I'm fine, I'm fine, it's just family
stuff but everybody like my immediate family is fine, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good,
I think I'll help my mom or something
where's mountain lion quest, that would be, oh my god, what was that game, oh my god, it was made
by this character called, this person called Kobu and it was like literally like lion simulator
and you can like do some really wacky, oh my god, it's like two hearts, oh my god, it's gonna
bother me but I might play that too at some point, I'm just gonna like, I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna
furry max, I'm gonna weasel my way into the furry community, honestly some of the furry models
that I've seen are really freaking cute, I think I saw her a bunny one or like a cat one or a dog
one and I'm like that's actually adorable but it was like Moe, you know, it was cute, she means
becoming a furry, that's the thing, I was always a furry though, I'm always angry, no I'm not a
furry, I do, I do admire the art though, I'm not really into that, like I, I'm trying to think
did I draw, no I only drew like, I never drew like anthropomorphic animals, I only drew like cat
girls or just cats, I never like a combination of like going even deeper in it, she be furry bum,
furry affiliate, oh yeah, no there's definitely, who are all the bunnies furries, I don't know,
ask, ask, I don't know, hey man, does werewolf not count as a furry, I think that's its own thing,
I respect furries a lot because it's not a chief hobby, honestly same
and they make a lot of bank, okay if you, if you complain that my model lags, I'm gonna punch you,
I don't care, it's gonna lag, my computer's old, I built it in 2017, leave me alone,
yes, could a veeler bought me a computer, yeah but I didn't want to ask because I'd rather the
money go towards something else, all right new game, um, I want to modify a wolf,
wait, yeah we're gonna create a wolf, if it loads in, I don't,
it just crashed,
should I, am I have to turn into like a fucking PNG to play this, I love this game, I do,
it's, it's close to my heart, but it just crashed, oh look there's two of me, hi,
attempt number two, are you hypnotized, are you hypnotized, are you entertained, are you feeling it,
shot of close jutsu,
this should be head incident part two, okay is it gonna go back to wolf quest,
police, oh no they'll make it that,
there we go, perfect, okay let's turn down the game settings even more, we're gonna put them at
fast, what fastest, perfect, everything is so, okay okay wait so this is the fastest version
and then this is the stupendous version,
it's actually quite pretty but my model can't move at all,
so we're going to be playing like this, I have, yeah I have a 10 to 70s so
I kind of like how ganky it looks because this is how I remember it, it looked like this,
the grass was barely there, it was a texture on the ground, the trees were barely loaded in,
actually hold on am I, I'm moving fine, what if I do,
about fast, just so we can have, that looks a little bit better, that looks a little bit better,
now we have some actual grass, so let's do, let's do a new game, create new wolf,
see oh it's working, we're good, oh my god girl we need to get you a better pc,
I will, don't worry I will eventually, I just want to, I have more things I want to do before I
get a pc, I have paying off my debt first, I need to pay off my credit card and then I will get a pc,
then I will put it on that credit card, get the points for it and then pay it off again because
I am a, I'm a smart bunny, madam and debt, madam is, I was about to say the amount of debt,
I don't really count school loans,
it's fine, I'm not going to say because then someone's going to start like donating shit and
I know that's not why I'm, I would bring it up, okay so I have, ooh life is rough pack,
cutie Cinderella, oh my god that's such a pretty wolf, I have to buy the dlc,
her name is 42f Cinderella but it's fine, white lady, that's what I am right now, I'm a white lady,
pretty, these are actual wolves, I actually, it's funny because I, I love like learning
about Yellowstone and stuff so I recognize some of these names because I remember I would,
when I used to be a wolf role player, I was an avid wolf role player on WolfQuest and on like
wiki foundry, aka wet paint and all that shit, we would take the photos from like the famous
wolf pictures and like that would be our OC, like this is my wolf character,
so it's funny that I, like the, the founder ones I recognize, it's just, it's just because I was
just such a, I just really liked wolves because I liked their pack mentality, like the family,
what happened to him, life is rough pack, oh he just has freaking mange, I don't want that,
it's kind of badass, as long as you don't sleep with the fishes, I was a lone wolf in the game,
related wolf, what, you know cats, does it entail like normal death, wolf looks like ice,
yeah she's the white one that did, if, if icy was a wolf, she would be this one, this would be her,
it's so cute, um I, so there's different pack types and there's different um coat types because
wolves come in a variety of coat colors, um I like this one because it looks like me,
because we are both like blondish, why is this one named Brad Pitt, hold on let me move myself over
a little bit, let me make myself a little bit smaller, because I'm blocking a lot of stuff,
my big ass hand, you indulge collab game, oh my god, mischief null, maybe I'll name her that,
um okay, let's make her, I can make myself, oh fuck, there's so much like before, it used to be
like a little wolf and then like a splash page over here on this side, you can't see my mouse,
I don't know why I'm just string, on the left side and then you would just have to pick a
color, you couldn't do all this cool shit or it wasn't based off of actual wolves, um I can give
myself some fucked up eyes, holy shit, I can miss an eye, like I'm winking at you, I kind of like
that, like I'm a little like, I'm winking, I'm winking, uh thank you Charlie for the donut,
wolves and dogs are actually the same species, canis lupus, dogs are substance of the wolf,
you think if I am a, I love wolves and I wouldn't know that but thank you for the information
in the super, I do know, I already knew that, yes, um my cats are playing in my pants that I took
off and I need to put some pants back on actually because my, my hoo-ha is cold, okay let me find
one, just sit here, sure, hi, can you take that, there you go, you have to take that
Lumi, why are you all, he's all amped up, he's playing with his favorite toy, hi pretty boy
oh, aren't you funny, Ninkadargui tipped four dollars and 20 cents, shibii cute
okay, my legs are amply covered
I'm ready to become a wolf guys, I am so ready, I'll say it again, as I said before
in the famous words of bow, the whale, throw me to the wolves and I will come back pregnant
we are wolves, we run it, oh yeah, what the hell is that, tick tock sound, I'm all cringing so
hard on that, wait did I just hear a, am I tripping, did I just hear a voice
oh wait it's my neighbors, okay that just scared the shit out of me, I found somebody
I'm like am I, am I going insane, Texas speech is very loud
oh it was the Texas speech that I heard, that makes sense, it must be loud then, um
I can turn that down a bit but then you guys won't really hear the music
thank you Ninkadargui, shibii cute, thank you for the anonymous tip, 20 dollars debt, cough, PC fault
you guys are too good
okay, mademoiselle had a male voice, yeah I thought, and I realized yeah it was a Texas
speech because I'm like am I tripping, the AI thought I was a streamer for some reason, must be
signed, that's, what, thank you for the other five dollars, um let me turn, because yeah you
guys can't hear the music at all if I turn that down
yeah I know you don't hear any music, it's because I put it down
because it's really loud
but I guess I'll put it up more because it's for some odd reason, it just doesn't
it's fine, I didn't get far
can you hear now
thank you expose me for dochi, oh I fucking love dochi, if you like dojikai you like dochi
yeah yeah okay
I think the Texas speech is gonna be loud, I'm not sure, I'm scared
I'm terrified, it's gonna happen, oh thank you authorities, thank you, what the hell bro
oh sorry I don't know that
get away system sounds, we don't need you
bye
I'm not good with sounds guys, I just, sounds sounds
occasional great name, you can go see that's like everybody must be green, thank you, hopefully
some of the people that have been hoping to be randomly gifted will get it because they're just
like I'm poor and I'm like that's okay and then that one person that just like kept getting
missed over and over again when people were just like dumping gifted
that was me, congrats everybody's like the great names are just like sad
don't worry, don't worry you're still appreciated, you're still appreciated, you showed up today
that's all I care about, um gray wolves coming out, the grays versus the greens, it's house of
the wolves instead of house of the dragon, if you were in a Game of Thrones house what would you
do, oh it's your lucky day, some of you, it's your lucky day, thank you authorities,
one of you got hit, that's good
there he goes, dubs in the chat boys, dubs in the chat, if I was in Game of Thrones house
I would leave
I feel like I would be like appearance wise, one there's like no brown people except in
over the seas in um what should I call it, wherever
Melisandre is from, no that's the red woman, Melisandre, Misandre is from
but I feel like I would be in house motel based off of appearance if it was a house but I would
I would prefer, I would probably be based off of my model obviously a fucking lannister like
let's be real like I can't like a red and blonde come on like and then Amy would also be a lannister
because like kissing your sister and stuff so gotta keep it, I gotta keep it in the family
but if I would, I would probably, I would obviously, I'd probably be a star because I like the winner a
lot, Dorne, yes Dorne, I'm a Dorne-ish gal, who house the dragon mansion, oh there's a new episode
tonight guys, I was like yelling at my dad because he forgot to pay our subscription because I just
like steal my parents subscriptions for streaming services and like dad you did not pay the HBO
he's just like sorry I'll work on that I'm like so I hope it's freaking fixed today
and trying to be daughter of the kraken you mean she would be house um fuck what house was he from
fuck I can't remember the houses
HBO, I'm like HBO no thank you, only decent lannisters with two brothers, Greyjoy, yes thank you
should be house Greyjoy that name never made sense to me for the house name like I just it really
didn't okay well if you guys your eyes your ears are gonna bleed if you hear the stream elements
thing so it sucks for you guys but people can scream their names their their their truth from my
text to speech because they don't feel like fiddling with that right now what am I doing I'm
like automatically going to game settings it's all I've been doing I've been streaming for
30 minutes doing fuck all um fine mate mate cannot die well we'll do easy
what's accurate damn Jesus fuck
eastern dens western dens
I think I played eastern dens before so I'll do western dens um when I played this in my PO
show only iron walls I don't even know what the fuck that means what the fuck is an iron wall
okay I think that's is that like the current pack that's dominating yellowstone
wouldn't it be Targaryen since they married or something's true but she's blonde like in terms
of like appearance she'd be a lannister icy would be free folk 100% icy would be free folk
iron wolves if you die you die oh
really why does it say show only iron wolves then well um
let me get down here please oh no it crashed again oh she's back she's back everybody it's fine
I got nervous it's cool let's just turn her this way um I'm female thank you just a
miniscule smaller um I'll make myself a little bit more a little bit yellow
my eye color what color my eyes are orange oh I can make my eyes green why is it
or gray oh they're like kind of orangey can I make them a little bit brighter yeah
bright orange eyes let's go let's do a little wink a little saucy wink oh wait I can't do a
fucking wink okay because I have to buy the LC it's dumb howl
oh that's that's the classic wolf quest howl
that's very mournful that's what you sound like that just sounds like airy siren
um
that was pretty badass I like that one it's my secondary and my primary oh wait I can
use my controllers I forgot got my primary my secondary howl
oh wait no I might just do might as well just do all the customization and shit
in on my keyboard can I please put this down
oh this wire is weighing my headphones down two different howls yeah 10 is nice I like 10 10 solid
um I can give myself some cool ears uh I would like two floppy ears because I would be adorable
can I do both
because I have floppy ears oh my god it's me for real for real um we love it we're a little floppy
eared gal we're cute I could oh I could add myself I can get some like cool stuff I can have a
snaggle tooth I can't do I need the DLC for that I can have a main g tail nice
I don't want to buy the deal why isn't it showing me oh oh little snazzy collar
what's a body mask do oh I can speak myself plump be a plump cheek ruff oh
oh give me that oh wait this is a cheek I thought it was a booty cheeks
I was like nothing's happening
oh
it's fine like that back curve
nah I got that scoliosis oh oh oh oh um fluffy tail
like a fluff I'm a I'm a bunny so you got a fluffy tail I would do a cut off tail if I could
I don't mean to have this radio collar let me take that off um but that's part of the DLC
which I'm not going to buy because that would be silly um I'll have a fluffy tail though
fluffy tail oh okay uh stamina 100 wait
what I don't have any points
they're all in zero how can I so I just do like minus everything like
have my health be absolute shit like what do I do
whoo I'm gonna have stamina and speed
sure I don't fucking know
you need to put one in nine of them yeah you don't think I noticed that I feel like you guys think
I'm a lot stupider than I am which is true but write your bio here um throw me to the wolves
and I'll come back
pregnant nant um personality I'm a little bit bold I'm a little social uh I think a little bit lazy
iron wolf lives on the edge always one false move from permanent death
can you not create it no I don't feel like doing that we're not we're not they're making this to
a fucking rule like um I need a name uh I'm not gonna call myself sheebie because that's stupid
we have to do of a cool wolf name um no I'm not going into a public server she's a bower
it's funny because I know I'm not even a bowery but that came up on my feed and I was literally
dying at it for like 15 minutes like I was I was losing it I thought it was so funny
she's the wolf king of the gun gile yeah showbo no
dark see exactly dark fang gold fang you want it's like the warrior cat's naming you have to
I think the last time I named when I played on my pl I named it after one of my first
wolf quest characters which was sorrow song because that's badass um and it's funny because
he was a dude he was just a little emo boy um and I also had death song because I was just hard
core uh fanatos crayon I don't know why I named her that mitzuko I had so many like wolves
evil needs more edge exactly I have like I think I took a picture of all the names of my
wolves I had like 50 from across all my characters from wolf role playing
my favorite one's name and the one I used the most was
wait I can't even spell it
erotomanthias because in um when I'm like the like thing for wolf role playing
on wet paint wet paint a week of foundry was that you had either a super fucking long name
that was like greek inspired or it was something edgy like that bark follow me yeah it was after
it was a riff of erotomanthias yes um and remember when I said I also had a character
named Arta Xerxes maybe I should just make a male wolf no I want it to be me I need to think
of a cool but I didn't play a lot of female wolf characters for whatever reason it's just easier
posing to be a guy online because then you just get harassed when you're a woman so it's just
like yeah I'm a dude um I'm trying to think of the girl I think I had Cersei for one of the girl
names this is not like Cersei like from Game of Thrones like actual Greek mythology Cersei
um actually a death song was female I saw as mitzuko
guys give me a color wolfrodiety that's pretty good
pandora andromeda that's pretty cool atlanta please the guys give me give me
give me a color madamantius
char truce selena is not a color but thank you brown period full stop okay we're gonna be
how long can my name be char truce I don't know if I spoke that right it's fine um I didn't
wait how do you spell char truce
char trees char tree
there we go is that how you spell char true I don't know if I'm wrong
frisky magician okay and then give me a part of a body of a wolf body so like claw fang ear eye
nose or or a nature like leaf pool the more like pool as in body of water uh bark
char truce not
not
ear because of my own because my fucked up ear you vote not
okay I guess we're char truce not
it wait but she's a girl why don't we call her char truce not let's see
we're not calling her char truce not guys
what if she's a food no not like this char truce cooch oh that's good there we go char
truce cooch perfect what else do I need to do do I have something
do we need to do I need to buy the dlc for that one oh the body modifier
okay what what body modifier which body modifier do I have on
what oh it's a fucking snaggle tooth that's what was on okay we are char truce cooch
we're two years old we cannot die we're starting easy we're just gonna do amethyst mountain
what's lost river that's new
hell roaring mark what the fuck are these ones
that's cool um we're gonna do the classic amethyst mountain
star game was selected
I actually recognize this literal video because I'm weirdo
can you make her neon green I can't she want that dog and
almost 40 minutes we're getting there you guys know it takes me a while
char truce cooch the knotted one perfect that is her title
no we're not gonna we're not buying the dlc
uh actually no I might just to support them because I donated a lot when I was when I was
younger I was like I was I remember how old I was well I remember I was not gonna say um
back when I was uh 42 yes I'm 56 now so when I was 42 wow look how sparse the fucking
thing is because whatever um I donated like so much money to it because I was like save the wool
save them wolf customization is the most important I spent like two hours customizing
character in oblivion leave me alone that's why I like I don't think I could play balder's gate
because I'd just be sitting there customizing the character for the entire stream all right
I'm like too high up in my chair I need to like come down to earth my feet sees are kicking
comfy so much shit in this chair
tiny sheebie I just got lower and I think you can tell with my model that I got lower
because I'm just like all the way back here and just go forward
yep that would be me oh my god the amount of time I spent customizing character in black desert
for like three times right like I literally I took the heels off yeah I literally played
balder's gate for three hours and two hours of that was probably making my character
oh my god I should play the sims I think um as there is probably gonna make us in the sims or
something oh wait I meant to read that it's fine whoa I'm so far away from a mic as a new arrival
here in Yellowstone's Lamar valley you must learn how to hunt the prey animals here mostly elk
but mule deer and moose you'll have to become a good hunter before you can okay we're gonna skip
this because I already know how to fucking hunt because I'm a real wolf I'm a I'm the best wolf
you've ever met bro make myself a little bit bigger the wolf badge provides key information
about your wolf lose health doing attacks and biting yep yep yep don't need tips can I get a
little bit closer oh geez what the fuck whoa why am I so far away how do I get closer okay that's
how I sit and I lay down I can just really chill oh my god that's so cute what the hell
okay that's okay circle is to piss got it that's an important button somebody write that down
um mouse golders you know I'm playing with controller because it's just easier for me to
chill this way instead of leaning forward on my desk square is a howl cool set view left bumper
look at this look at that cool imagine you could smell shit like this IRL
um this is the stalk left trigger is the stalk
what is why does rape bumper not do anything
how the fuck do I attack
maybe it's like why am I so fucking fat why are we going so fucking fast bro
all right let's find a find a dude let's find a homeboy I need to find a dispersal male
I thought that was a wolf but it's just a branch
how do I turn down the fucking sensitivity on this
controls
emotes name tag oh push free cam fight oh okay
target lock on is the right oh got it got it got it
this is for an xbox controller though
uh I have a place to use your controller but it's fine
I can jump I'm so fast
get the fucking rabbit we're getting it die
get actually got wait can I eat it yeah you see that shit that's how I it's how I eat the
harem members yeah I just fucking killed a rabbit this cannibalism it's the a train
don't you hate it when you're looking for some sweet thing and it turns up to be a tree
look at all these trees they're dead I think this is what is this part of the map the burn
nope that's not it yes this is the map uh there's a part of the map called the burn oh it's all
the way back there we're at spawn rock
so yeah we're on a different part of amethyst mountain because there's another part of this
map that's bigger so this isn't the like the og og map um the eastern one would be the og map
but we did the western one cool I can be eight years old damn all right how do I change the
camera sorry I'm so freaking this out
is there like push is free cam
okay because normally you can like have a gonna be a little bit oh okay this is better I just
scrolled with my mouse instead perfect Jesus I'm so fast can I like go really in no I can't
I'm sorry if you get motion sick from how fucking fast I'm going
hello
go this way we gotta follow the wind it's a hair coyote we need to smell out some males
is there a boy smell boy smell boy smell boy smell we are looking for boy smell
feel the wind in your hair good in your hair get it oh let's get let's get a
knock let's get a knock let's get a knock or the fuck this is I'm so fast this looks like a
why are they jumping how do I
can I run faster
oh oh oh shit yes I can run faster hello
go go go go go wear him down wear him down wear him down we got it we got it lock on this one
instead get out this one instead oh or not it's fine don't worry about it oh we lost the lock we
lost the lock it's okay I just got hit it's fine don't worry about it fuck him up
fuck him up oh I have to hold it
come here get got get got get got get got get got get got get got get got
die die die die die you're dragging my ass downhill oh he's trying to fight back bitch
grab me by the throat come here oh we got her we got her boys she's done she's done she's gone
easy claps my leg wolf callouts going crazy I know I sometimes we want more gore um
sometimes I like will play games like I'm playing fucking CS go or valorant I'm like
like up top up top it's going B going B
on bomb
oh because it's just like I'm so used to talking like that
what the fuck is this crow coming from howl to remember carcass how do I howl
go away you fucking birds I'm so fast still
I'll tell you to turn off the fucking run what's happening
I'm I'm going too fast I'm going
delicious do I even need to eat I don't even think I'm hungry look at this little
fucking crow dude I don't know if you guys ever read like fel fel used to be one of my favorite books
I can't tell which one is my food meter I'm too full okay cool enjoy wait I need to howl
I need to howl to remember uh nope that's to sit
hardcore perfect okay again I am fast as fuck can I please slow down what is the toggle for that
I forget I feel like my normal speed is my running speed oh wait I remember it's this one
okay now we're good I think we're near another wolf's territory let's put on this let's put on scent view
I don't know what the fucking random noise was um
we need to look for some scent markers there's a grizzly bear oh shit there's a grizzly bear
we can't fight a grizzly we're not fighting a grizzly
your eyes hurt from the speed I'm so sorry
old days of youtube yes this is this is what my friend oh this grizzly is nearby guys this grizzly
very close oh what's this what's this this is piss
wait I smell oh it's a female I'm a I'm a female wait did I accidentally click myself as male
I don't care about female dispersal wolves from the Abrasoka pack
maybe they'll lead me to boys though maybe we can all hang out together I'll be our own little girl
group I'm looking for some real real manly wolves in these parts all right
all right
all right I'm just gonna fall because if the if they're nearby then I will run into
female I mean male wolves soon no lesbian wolf I wonder if you can even romance
wolves like like just be gay just be a gay wolf
uh let me howl because usually they'll hollow back can I not howl in sun view no that's me laying down
and then when you howl it will usually mark on the map who's nearby which is nobody apparently
you worry for our wolves chastity there's no chastity in these parts why would I be
chased I'm trying to make babies I'm trying to cub max I'm trying to pup max over here
I'm also mad at that I'm like not healing
oh there might be wolves over here oh there we go men men
hello is that a boy I smell
two-year-old wolf exactly the boy the clippers are gonna love this where are you boys
I'm a two-year-old female ready to mate female wolf that's not just female because
all right they howl back we're going let me check the scent nothing okay
okay
nothing on the scent cues oh there is am I in a pack territory I think I am
nope map
uh show pack territories okay I that's actually helpful I'm at I'm in the what PT lake territory
I'm gonna be I'll be running so fast I'm in blue territory I'm in crypt territory
uh can I smell anyone what is that over there what's that blue thing I kind of want to go check it out
let's go check out the blue thing that I see in the distance on scent cam
oh look at that look at that water beautifully rendered water
making myself fucking nauseous I'm having stick drift no I'm not okay let's just walk
how about that let's just take a stroll let me back up a little bit I hope they like my floppy
ears I'm kind of self-conscious about that my floppy ears as a female wolf so
I hope they don't think I can't get it up or anything as a female wolf
what the fuck are these dough just doing they're just doing dough shit
they're like freaking out um let's smell what's this what's that
is this a scent marker oh it's a scent post uh-huh okay
what the fuck is this boss music
floppy ears show's age no I'm a young hip wolf
I'm looking for a boy toy you know aren't we all just looking for a boy toy
can I get a call back
oh there's a boy toy in this direction
don't worry I'm coming for you boy toy you can't hide from me oh stranger wolves
stranger things oh is there any dispersal wolves among this though
I only see actuals like scents I might run into these wolves I made I hope I don't have to fight
them because I don't feel like playing feel like playing um Dark Souls wolf addition oh
hi there what's up are you aggressive oh you are aggressive uh please don't hurt me I'm chill
I'm chill I'm chill bro I'm chill look I'll get on the ground I'm showing obeisance
please don't hurt me I'm just a little girl I'm so innocent you're just gonna growl at me and
look around see I'm just being till bro I'm just being chill now I'm gonna howl till I'm just looking
for a boy he hasn't attacked me yet so I guess we're chill we're cool we're cool oh
he's fucking chasing me too bad I'm fast as fuck boy I'm fast as fuck boy I'm fast as fuck boy
eat my fucking tushy boy call me keemstar because I'm fast as fuck boy
is he still following me
can I run and howl no that said there was a boy in this direction
why is there only one wolf out here why is he still am I don't want to fight you bro
oh oh over here over here over here over here over here there's one over here am I getting closer
far across the distance in space okay I'm out of that get can you fucking leave me alone dude
I'm just trying to find a boyfriend and you're on my jock
what the fuck dude I'm trying to howl
oh he just bit me in the the chartreuse couch dude
I'm trying to oh I don't want to fight you why are you still on me
I don't want to kill him I will probably die oh fuck I'm on the edge of the map
please let me go fine fine you want to fight you want to fight you want to fight
you want to stop biting me
please please please please please stop let me go you motherfucker
okay I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill you and hold on I have to figure
this out first how to kill you come here come here oh my god I'm so fast
ow ow okay he might kill me before I can
I need to slow down and toggle my
oh how is he attacking me
come here come here come here ow I can't turn my speed is hindering me okay we're just gonna
leave we're just gonna leave we're just gonna leave we're just gonna leave we're just gonna leave
we're out of here we're out of here we're out of here we're out of here we're out of here
we're gone we're gone
Just fucking buffalo maybe the buffalo will distract him
Why are you running why are you running? I'm not that it's cuz I'm in another packed territory and I'm weak
This guy's still fucking following me
He's still following me dude
Dude bro, I'm literally getting making myself fucking dizzy. Can I like back up? Okay, that's better. Oh
My god fuck off
Fuck off
Fuck off. Yeah, you fucking run bitch you fucking run come here come here come here
Come back here motherfucker you don't get to run away come here
Can I lock on you
Come here. Come here. Come here. I'm gonna fucking kill your ass now. I'm the alpha. I'm the alpha come here
Why are you so fast why can't I why can't I catch up?
Oh
Fucking cunt
Okay, well I'm time to knock out
Yeah, fuck I'm gonna take the risk
Am I gonna die is this wolf gonna attack me while I'm sleeping
He just walked over and then disappeared into nothing
You have negative one speed
I
Can't walk is focus on your territory wall in a fight you tell me I can't pee
Okay, let me get out of here. Let me get out of here. Let me get out of this fucking territory
Let me look at the map. Oh damn. I'm only the edge. I'm going the wrong way
Go away, bro. I don't I don't have the time to deal with your
Ridiculousness
Yeah, he said his bro to come get me he's just like he sent the ops after me dude, I don't even
It's weird saying this with the model that I use
But
Where's your killer bite so I'm about to die from a killer bite
At least I have amazing night vision, who are you?
Hold on I'm eating
Are you taking my food?
Ow
Okay, let me turn off toggle fuck I
Can't shake them off. Okay. Bye die
Come here. Come here. Come here. Just chasing each other in circles
I don't think I feel like it's the computer like it's not supposed to
Fucking come here. Come here, bitch
Get actually dead bro. Oh wait. Oh, I thought I was attacking you come here
Why can I only attack you when you're behind me?
Die I'll kill you male. I'll kill you
Come here
Yeah, get fucked. Oh fuck
Oh, what he just literally just like
Die I'm the alpha I'm the alpha
I'm gonna leave because I'm actually like low health
You really want to fucking go again, bro
I'll keep attacking you I
Swear to God if you don't back the fuck off. We're gonna have problems
Okay, I don't have time for this. I need I need to find a boyfriend. I don't need to fight people
Where's the map?
I'm going the wrong way again
Who is howling
Was it you
Is it the same wolf howling
Oh, there's a lot of wolfies nearby
Oh
enemies to lovers are
Be pretty hot
Be guys into liking her sounds like oh, yeah. Yeah, I'm just like I'm trying to put the mails in their place so I can just like
Make them my boyfriend, you know
How one's too far away where's the closer up one I
Don't understand what that little fucking thing is
No, there was one over here. Where did it go? Oh?
There it is closer
Closer barrel
I don't see anything on the wind. There's nothing on the wind. Okay. Keep heading south keep heading south keep heading south
Look gorgeous the sky is
Am I being chased by something again, that's a scent marker
Let me stop and howl. Oh
What oh
What the hell is happening? I'm being attacked by multiple
Oh my god guys, I might die guys. I might die guys get me out of here
I
I'm just getting fucking ganged up on guys. This is not the type of gang bang that I wanted. Let me go
Stunlocked they killed me
No, you died
Let's just fuck off you bitches
I
Was a back in time you died. This is a badass picture of a crow. I
Couldn't get out of that. There's three wolves on me
They probably just ate me
It's so wolf over okay, at least I oh fuck this guy
Okay, hold on. Let me go towards okay. This is the right way speed up speed up speed up
Wait, I don't think I can find hold on
All my questions I have to kill two elk before I can even find a mate Jesus. That's why I haven't been seeing any males
All right. Well, I got to go kill two elk hold on
Oh
There's a moose I can't really take down a moose
But this dude is still but behind me
Dodger all do wolves cannibalize. Um in certain circumstances. They will definitely cannibalize
Are these elk? No, they're they're deer
Yeah, they're dope wrong here. I don't really need that. I already killed a fucking deer. You think that would count
Is this dude still on me? I will literally laugh
He's not wait, is he? Oh my god
So no elk
Maybe he just wants to hang out with me. Do you want to be my boyfriend?
You know, I don't mind a little bit of roughness. I'm not I'm not averse to that
Wait, is that another wolf? Oh, no, it was a fucking I'm getting distracted by dead trees and thinking that they're wolves
I'm just trying to find I'm leaving your territory. Are you happy?
There was a grizzly bear an hour here, and there was a mule deer
Am I out of the territory? Please. Let me be out of the fucking territory. I
Think I am
Little hexagon changes color. Oh
Oh my god, he's still following me
Okay, now I'm in purple territory, so I should be okay
Yeah, he's howling cuz he's Victor. Oh, I think I already fucking figured that out. All right, I think these are deer
Stop howling who's howling. Oh, it's definitely him. That's howling. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, whatever
Wait, where'd the deer go?
No, I need elk I don't need deer. I need elk. Where are the elk? Where's the elk at?
Looking for some prime elk
I do got that stamina I
Don't know what does purple mean that I'm hungry. I don't or that I'm thirsty or something
I don't remember what that stands for
Okay, that's definitely another same little from the pack. Oh, so the colors mean it's who's howling
That makes a lot more sense. Okay, again, this game has changed a lot
And I didn't really go through it the mechanics of it back when I
Started playing it before recently
Where am I?
I'm in the center. I'm in no territory
Just kidding. I'm in territory now. I'm not um
Maybe
We're at some fucking out. Can I drink water? Do I need to like do that? Do I need to like? Oh, I
I'm standing awkwardly on a rock and I'm drinking water
That's pretty cool
Sweet nice
But what does the purple stand for is that my because I'm tired
Anything anything on the breeze, no
Pronghorn
You'll dear I feel like somebody's on me. No, okay
You know those trees look promising
We're birch trees in the line
They're like perfectly spaced. This is kind of a weird
No
Nothing here
Just the wind in the trees you saw an elk herd. Where's the elk herd? What do you mean? You saw an elk herd?
What do you mean?
I'm trying to eat it. I don't want to pick it up. Let me eat it. Am I not hungry?
Okay, I was gonna say I'm like what the fuck
Oh, I'm full. Okay. Go orange is hunger. I don't know what purple is
Where was it in the scent? I did what you're lying to me. I
Did not smell any I only saw
Hold on cougar. I'm going too fast
Grizzly sow grizzly. What is this some grizzly mom? You know, that's what they called that
What is this pink elk herd? Okay?
Oh, aren't you funny? Oh, that is loud 20 cents inside of you there are two wolves and that's pretty hot
This is abandoned coyote
Okay, we're going we're going we're going we're going we're going this elk herd this way elk herd
Nope, that's fucking mule deer. Oh
Fuck you
Herd I just need an elk herd, please
Okay, we're getting closer. It's this way
Closer closer closer closer closer
Oh, that's another I was like why is there a yellow thing floating
Stranger wolves. Oh fuck. I hope I don't run into some stranger wolves. I probably will
Well, I'm trying to fight these fucking
Get out of this view see if I can just see them. I can coyote
I need to scratch her back express yourself
What aggressive snarl
Growls at you did you won't follow
Okay
Well, that's the hair where did the elk it was so close and it's gone. Oh wait, okay, we're getting closer. I think
Okay, please it's like it. Where are they moving? I
Feel like I'm gonna run into wolves before I run into the fucking elk herd
I definitely will I can already tell
Oh
Is that them is that them oh, baby
How do I crouch? Oh, that's a jump
Don't guard your child from me
Uh, how do I crouch I did it before
This this elk is just staring me down
Stock walk. Oh, okay, okay, okay
To this one come on
Can I eat your baby?
Let me eat your baby your baby's mine
Your baby's mine
Nice try lady
My injured, why is my stamina solo?
I'm killing your child just let it happen
Lady you can't stop mother nature. She's dead. Yeah, run off. She's mine
Now I'm gonna eat her
Okay, well I'm gonna pass out now right next to the carcass
I'm gonna take the risk
I'm asleep right next to it
Damn nature you scary
You go for the young
So wolf gonna show up. Oh, uh, there's a grizzly. Oh, oh, I think I should leave
I'm gonna go. I hope you guys enjoy
I'm just gonna go hunt them again
Let me find another baby. I think I see one speed up speed up speed up come here child. Yeah, you're a baby. Oh
You're also weak
Nice try mom it's already dead
Your child's dad leave it or I'll kill you too your next bitch
Don't come eat
Can I eat it? I've learned to hunt
We can find a mate you think I can bring him some meat you think they'd like it if I brought him some meat
I think I should bring him some meat. I
Think it'd be cool if I brought him some meat
Uh, what is oh
It's a moose. I was like what's happening here. They couldn't tell what it was for a second. Oh, that's moose
I'm scared of Mises
I'm good on the moose. Okay, which way should I go?
Time to put max. Okay, we're gonna go towards the center cuz I can get out of the territory
So I can sleep because I'm overtired
We're zooming we're zooming what's that song is it by like cake?
She's maxing and daxing. She's going to run. She's running so fast. She's gonna find a mate
She needs to pass out. It's getting really late
Where am I
She gives me I got me he wanna oh, that's not the map. I'm going the wrong way and you go this way
Actually, I'm pointing in the right direction
Need to sleep
I'm so tired
From trying to find a boyfriend
Retired from no sleep
Why am I not out of the territory yet
Tarot tree is so big
The beautiful sky I'm gonna I'm gonna sleep right in the open. I'm gonna sleep right by this rock
Let me see if that'll actually help. I just sleep a little bit
Take the risk
I'm dreaming of moose. Oh, I thought they killed me
Run run run run
The birds are screaming just like me internally
Leave me alone. I got three dudes on my ass
The Sun is about to rise
Am I still being chased?
Whoa, I just want it to make babies
Not another 3v1. Okay, I should be out very soon. I
Keep running straight because anything towards the middle is usually good. Maybe if I get over this ridge
Nope, I'm just in another section
Okay, let me just
Okay
Okay, this way
I'm going to eat myself off this cliff. Why is there a cliff here?
Why am I not now? Oh
Please oh
Walk I'm going straight across instead of down. No, I'm going the wrong way
Okay, it's fine. We'll just go into red territory. Oh shit. Oh fuck
Hold on
Hold please
How can they do it and I can't
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, we go up we go up
We're almost out. We're almost
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm just gonna slide down this cliff like a bad bitch
So leave me alone
I'm not even I'm not even touching my controller besides to move the camera
Oh
Feels like a bad idea, it's fine. I can't move can I jump
Can I please jump oh male dispersal wolves is that a boy I smell
Can I please move
If those wolves could shut up that would be actually great
Apparently smell dispersal wolves just again, that's their marker
Okay, I have to climb this cliff to get back to where I need to be I hate it here
I need to work on my Riz I what do you mean I know I am the Riz Lord just wait just wait till I find a nice
the fuck
It's a loud ass bird a nice available male, you know
Let me do a little howl let me do a little awoo any boys around any any available bachelors
No, oh
Boy
boys
Go towards the boys
No, I can't climb
Let me over this cliff. I must mate. Oh
Fuck it's these guys
They're close by. Oh wait, but I'm still in I'm not in their territory. So it's fine
Wait, I accidentally cut off my own how
She's after a lover and her exes won't stop her
Okay, go in this direction
Whoa, whoa, I'm getting dizzy
I need to sleep I'm gonna pass out I might as well just sleep here on this cliff
See that's me. I'm having dreams about our pack
And cougars apparently and grizzlies dancing. I like how it's the same picture and they didn't even bother flipping it. Oh
No, I'm poor defenseless thing. Oh, what the fuck did you come from your four-year-old male
Diversity would be good
You're looking for a mate
Okay. All right
Let's how how do you measure up? I usually don't like older men, but you know it is
You're maybe you're you're pretty cute. Can we talk?
I mean, can we talk? Can we you want to you know do a little talking?
You want to I
Don't think he's interested in me guys
Okay, I need to emote
I didn't mean to growl at you
But
Me let me look a little bit closer. Let me get a little closer. Are you howling see he thinks I'm hot. He's howling
Um, I don't know how to do this. How do I go up?
Yeah, I'm just gonna use
I'm gonna I'm gonna T2
I
Whatever that means, I don't I don't really think he's interested to me guys
I'm gonna
I'll do a confident tail wag
He's from antelope pack that's kind of a dumb ass pack name. I don't think I like you I
Don't think you're good enough. Nah
I'm looking for a better man
Man closer in age. I need strong puppies
Although, you know, you have been around for a bit, but you know, you're just on my type
Let's try to find another boy boy toy
Sniff is what Charlie? Thank you for the super but what?
No, nothing can I get a little holler back a little howl back girl
All right, let's go up
He me coping
Elevator is shut up. He wasn't good enough. He wasn't good enough. I'm sorry. He just wasn't why is it black?
Wolf failure
He was he was giving me nothing. How can I get he wasn't giving me the same energy back
He just sat there and howled and I wagged my tail. So I don't think it's gonna work out
So we're gonna go to whomever this is
Why am I getting like no sense usually there's a lot more wolves around
I have to run all over fucking creation to find a boyfriend like hello
You started getting your ass kicked no, he was intimidated by me
Because he saw me being the shit at a one dude and then he also saw all my boyfriends who were chasing me out last time
So that's why mm-hmm
Why is there's that tree looks like it's sparkling but it just isn't rendered properly I
Should just do the thing I did before and just go to sleep and then a male will show up
I just wake up and there's a dude
I think I might just do that because I don't feel like running all over the place just to find a man
They can come to me, you know they can come to me. I'm gonna sleep by this rock. It's good shelter
Let's take a nap
He's a flat justice site, maybe you know, I respect that
Am I gonna wake up dispersal wolves ready? Oh
Hi men can I how's it going? What's up?
Okay, two of them really like me he's two years old you're
From eight mile the movie your two years your four years. Hmm, but you like me a lot
What what do you got? Let me let me look a little bit closer. Can I look at you?
You're cute. You kind of look like me and
Then you're a nice-looking
wolf
We would have a really good diversity
We could be a little mixed-race couple
And we can have little mini-meese
But like I don't know this guy likes me more. They're all from eight mile pack
Guys, who should I go with?
What do you mean Jesus, I'm just saying I have lots of eligible bachelors here. I don't know who to choose
Menage a twat. No. Oh, you're hauling together. I'll haul it with you boys. Oh
The darker one good diverse jeans
This is different versions of Marsal Mathers. Okay here. We'll put it to a vote. So you got 816, which is a nice gray
Gray white wolf you got
1217 which is a nice tan wolf like myself. You got
1218 which is oh, I don't know guys. He's kind of seducing me a bit. Are you trying?
Are you trying to emote with me, bro?
You trying to
Are we hanging out can I lock on oh I can lock on you
1218 everybody you think I you guys show like like normally I'm not into black dudes, but like
I
Know people are gonna be so mad
They're gonna be gonna take it away and be like wow
Either either she be it's either gonna be it's two choices
They're just gonna be like she be gets blacked or she be doesn't like black dudes. Oh
It's a game I'm making jokes for your enjoyment everybody fucking relax
It's not that serious. Oh my god
It just reminds me of the time where people were freaking out that Emmy got a toy that was like darker than it was supposed to be
People are like we're like sending her marrows like I feel I would be really
Disappointed in you if you used that I would be really like they said are the wrong one
They said are the wrong one an accident and people were getting mad, but they said are a wrong toy that was
It was so funny to me I'm like bruh
But maybe I should go for the black and white wolf, you know
Honestly, I think the diversity would be good for our puppies, you know keeps the the gene pools. Oh, he wants to howl with me
I'll howl with you
They just jealous
It just it literally just boggled my mind, but then I'm like, okay
Is that like would that be the equivalent of like me getting mad at like a male streamer for getting a
white
Toy instead of a black one and I'm like, no, I just
Don't care I'm like I don't take it that personally
Oh
But I'm like men are different
Men are different. They have different
insecurities
I am getting rizzed up. I should probably do something about it
Um, wait, don't rock away. He's just like don't come too close lady. Um
How do I
Hey, I have a little bit of roll. I'll give you a little bit belly in this bush. You want some bush in this belly?
Love is love
Do you like me you're not giving me anything I'm trying to like
Come here
Guys, I don't think he likes me. I'm like trying to be cute and he's not interested
Can you play bow with me
Please give the other chance a wolf to respond
You're convinced these wolves to get to know you better emo. Okay, we're gonna we're gonna court
I
Okay
What the fuck are you? Oh, am I courting all of you at once? What's happening here?
Bro. Oh, hi
You know, you're not hitting too bad yourself handsome, bro. I'm surrounded by men
Guys stop. Oh my god
Okay, um
There's a lot of there's a lot of sense in the air
Who wants to who wants to play bow?
Anyone want to play with me? Oh, hi, okay
Oh, that's really cute you guys are all very cute. Um, I'll do a little tail wag
Oh, they all like me guys they like my tail wag
Guys this is you guys these are my you're my harem. I'll do a little bit roll
If I
I'm feeling more like a whore than I ever have before
Trying to seduce. Oh, he lost interest. He just fucking walked away. Um, okay, so I guess it's down to you guys. Um
Oh
Like
Let me just I'll do a little
Play about I don't know who in particular. Are you seducing the guy? Is he gay? Is he going for the other dude now?
You know, I'm not gonna knock it. We're progressive out here
Um, am I supposed to like look at you while I do this? Oh
You're laughing too
She be showing the bits for free. I know you guys should be subscribing to my patreon before you get this sort of howl
You like that
There's more
In my description below if you check out my patreon
Are you see leaving? Oh, okay
All right, who's gonna
I'm gonna do a little confident tail wag
Oh, they all liked it. Oh, but the you know 12 18 is really liking me guys
I'm gonna name this is harem. This is harlot and this is trash
Can I have three boyfriends?
Because I would know my little harems. Can you guys all follow me because I'd be sick
Um, okay, let me turn around really vigorously. I'm gonna do a little grin
Like I'm smiling
You guys like that
They weren't interested. Okay. They didn't like that Riz
Um, what if I airplane my ears except I really can't because they're already floppy
I'm
I'm gonna do a confident tail wag. Why did you guys just court each other?
Why stop at three? Yeah, why can't one pack one mate? Why can't I just um
Take them all with me. Oh, I think he's not interested anymore. He just left
He's not interested. Okay, it's fine. Uh, that's okay
Oh, he really likes me guys, I think he might be the one
Wanna sniff noses
No
Do you want to sniff noses?
Wanna sniff noses
We're literally the same wolf except you're just a different shade
Oh
He likes me again. All right. Oh, but I don't well. I'm going too fast
Do you want to sniff they're like literally like doing stuff to each other and I'm I'm a little confused. I'll lick your face
Oh
Yo
No hearts for that one though. They what about can I give you a chin rest?
I'm the alpha. It's funny. They do this to like
demonstrate
Dominance, so I don't know why that's a courtship thing
Especially when I'm a I'm just like
I don't know what to do with myself
I'm so overwhelmed. There's too many people
Oh my gosh, he has a full heart
Guys, he has a full heart guys. He has a full heart. I think I don't know
Um, would you like to do a playboy?
You like that I see you watching
What about you
What about you you're pretty handsome. Oh
What the fuck just happened
You want to want to sniff noses what?
Oh, uh 12 18 already chose me
I'm taking 12 18 home apparently progress. You made an impression in 12 18 m
Now hunt and socialize together for several days so you can learn about each other's personality and abilities
Do you agree?
I can growl three times if I don't like him
Uh, sure that's fine
All right boy toy you're with me. Where did this fucking girl come from?
Who the fuck are you get the fuck out of here? These are my boys
Get them fucking get her. I don't like it get her. Oh wait, there's like
Oh, they're all from another pack. Okay, let's leave. Let's leave. Let's leave. Let's leave. We're out of here
We're out of here bro. We're out of here. We're out of here. We're out of here. Come on
Come on trigger tits
You want to howl together let's howl together
She caught her man cheating. Oh my god, what will you call him? Um, I don't know
We have to see how the trial period goes. We got to hunt together and shit. Let's take a little nap together
Let's let's go to sleep
Look at us. Look, it's a couple of girls just a couple of guys
Should have been me
breed
Slept for a long time. I hope a fucking bear doesn't randomly show up
Hi, honey, are you well rested?
Sleeping together at the first date. No, we just fell asleep in a discord call. He's a little kitten
I'm gonna call him. I'm gonna call him discord mod
If everything works out that is
Let me get a little bit closer
Should we chase the wolf in the game? What we want me to bite him? Come here. I don't know. I'm hissing at you
But yeah, oh my god, there's a fucking giant june bug on my screen
Door like my window screen and it terrified me because it's just staring at me through my window
All right, let's go hunting together. Um, let's go this way
Yep, they're really in this direction
Can't really tell
Okay, that's three hours ago but there's pronghorn
Mule deer, where's the pronghorn smell?
two hours and 55
Three hours. Okay, so it's this way, but like I don't want to go that way
What if I go like that way? Oh look all the like scent on the wind
let's go this way just because
We kind of void packs. I don't feel like fighting for our lives
Although it is very romantic
Discord mods to be fun today
I don't know. I have to think of a cool name for him has to be edgy
Maybe we'll call him like emo claw
Okay, that's great. Um, I smell a lot of stuff
Or we're not in a territory. I don't know why people are howling
He's howling back, uh
Because I ain't no howl back girl ain't no howl back girl
Can you like help me find a herd bro? Like you're kind of useless actually
He's kind of just following me. I don't
I don't know if he's living up to my expectations. I don't even already went. Oh
Okay, right there. That's fine
I remember I think the last time I played
Like the person like the little the wolf I chose just like didn't even follow me
I would have to like come back and be like come on. Come on
There's nothing in the air
So we need to go into a pack territory to like get food
Usually when there's like an eagle around that means there's like a carcass, but I don't think so
All right, let's just keep running straight. He misses the boys
Call him cat. He's a bit subby. Yeah, I guess he's a little maybe I'll call him subby
Whoa
Oh
Oh, we howl together we we like it. Um, let's go find some food girly pop
Perfect, perfect, perfect. Let's go you on it. We on it. Let's go. Let's go
Go for it. Maybe pop
We're going
Boom, boom
Locked on
He's kind of slow I'm much faster than him
I'm getting closer I'm coming for your ass. I'm coming for your ass. I'm coming for the ass
Help me. Oh, it's the fawn. Perfect. Help me. You're not helping me. Okay, you're helping me. That's better
Leave your child to die. It's fine. Well, I'm going to turn around and kill you
I swear to god if you don't let us kill her good. She's dead now. We feast now. We howl
Where you go
Excuse you. Did you just pick that up and what you don't want to eat with me?
I'm actually kind of mad
He literally just picked up food and walked away because he didn't want to eat with me
Um, well, I'm starting to think you're a dick. I don't think this is going to work out
I think I think we should see other people that just faded into the ground
Where are you going bro?
Bro
My mouth is full. Oh, sorry. Let me drop that
I
Said I can cancel it if I growl three times I'm growling I don't watch you
We're not working out. I'm sorry. You decided that I'm not good enough to eat with
Farewell discord kitten
Fucking piece of shit. Fuck you. Yeah, fucking I should kill him. Can I kill him?
Oh, no, I can only fucking
All right boys
He's better off
Yeah, I don't I don't like the passive aggressiveness. Am I gonna be able to smell things? I don't think I can smell in the rain that well
Um, let's go
Remember when we sat here and we walked around together
Yeah, oh wait, he's right in front of me
All right, let's go the opposite direction. We don't need this. We don't need that dead weight, you know
I don't need that. I don't need that dead weight
We're gonna howl and find ourselves a new man
I don't like brats
I don't feel I'm I don't feel like taming anybody. I need someone who
Will be a partner
I want a partner
Not somebody who can even
Okay, that storm actually crack just scared me. Um, wait, I could just fall asleep and men will show up to me again
Oh my god, am I gonna get struck by lightning while I'm sleeping?
We're feral today, you know, and taming anything. Yeah
Um, sure, who are you?
You're the dude from before you're back
You showed up last time
And I said you were too old for me, but you know, I really like your persistence
Let's try it. Let's try it. I like his persistence. He he he tried courting me before
He's loyal. He's just like he's sick. He just I don't know. He just showed up when I needed him, you know, like
He is he does seem like a ride or die
The bark is the howl is not it though. Um, but maybe we can work on that. So let's continue
I'll do a little play bow for you
Do you enjoy
Do you like the play bow
You're sitting
Is my play bow not good enough? Why did you wait for me to wake up then?
Can I
Are you interested
Are you just here to yell at me? Okay, let's do it
Uh, let's sniff noses
Sneef, sneef
Oh
He's literally me, but in gray
Does he have a floppy ear? Oh my god. We both have floppy ears. Maybe that's why he likes me
A03 just wanted to see if I'm okay. Maybe he's
Maybe he's just a friend. I don't know
Maybe old but I can still give you a good time. He's a bit of a fixer-upper. I don't know. He's cute
He's cute
Okay, all right. Hold on. Let's do a little
Let's do an uh, a little roll
Let me I don't need to I don't need to slow down. Don't tell me to slow down
I'm trying to get this over as fast as possible
And see if you're good enough for me 803
Like how I just fucking jump
You you're not even watching me
I don't really think he's that interested. I think he's just a good guy
Maybe I don't know
Hello
You gonna oh he just averted his gaze. He's such a sub
Okay, what a sub. I'm gonna establish my dominance
The chin rest
Except I'm not touching you, but it's fine
Oh, he's such a sub look. I'm looking away. He's so bashful
Sir, okay, I'll give you you know, I'll do a confident tail wag because I'm the I'm the alphas here
I am the one don't eat a gun to get respect up on the streets
Oh, you know wag your tail too. Aren't we just cute?
I'll like I'll give you a smooch
Or not
I don't know what the fuck just happened what I just do
Let's let's do a little sniff
No, sniff
He is I don't know, you know, how did the viewer get in the game?
Um, let's do a little
A little roll you like that
He just walked away
He just left
I'm like hurt. I thought he cared about me
I guess he couldn't handle my alpha, bro, it's fucking winter. I'm so fast
Guys, I don't know what to do. He's gonna go see his wife
Like why did he he literally just walk he was so close
I'm
I'm genuinely shocked
But it's fine
I guess he was I guess you you know, maybe he's a gay friend that yeah
It was like gasses you up and it's like you're when you're wingman
Or like maybe he's just being a good guy, you know what?
We're just it was it was right person wrong time, you know
It wasn't
It wasn't me. It was it wasn't him. It was me, you know
He was too intimidated. He didn't see me as an equal. He wasn't looking me in the eye
Um, I don't really need to eat right now
But if I
Sleep again, though, he'll show back up. He isn't into maybe he was just yeah, I don't know. I just got
I kind of just got
Jipped, but you know, I'll recover. I'm a big girl
Is anybody gonna, you know, respond to me or
What is that? Is that a fucking hair or what's happening down there? I think it's a bunny
I'm so far away
Like how I eat a hair carcass and like one bite. Um, let's take a little sip I suppose
Everybody hurt I'm gonna turn three. I'm gonna turn three and have no man
Current quest get a mate
Okay, I'm still two
Do you like my bio
If you just showed up, do you like my bow? Um, my name is chartreuse kooch
But yeah, I can get perks what the fuck
Um, let's how
I can't even the bio isn't true. I am lying to myself a little bit
It's a map look like we're going to the edge of glory
There's no wolves around bro. I'm gonna cry
There's no nobody wants me
Ain't nobody gonna match my freak
I don't even go on tech talk anymore, but that song keeps showing up just like in general in my day to day life
Just like on twitter ain't nobody gonna match my freak
Ain't nobody gonna match and I'm just like so sick of it
Of hearing ain't nobody gonna match my freak
I'm just gonna eat some bunnies real quick
There's a lot of society am I winning no
I had there's one dude who didn't want to eat dinner with me and he literally picked up his food as left
It was the equivalent of a like just like oh, I need to go use the bathroom real quick
And then just left me with the bill and then another dude
I woke up and he was just like just trying to make me feel better and I was coming on to him
But you know, he wasn't interested. He just walked away right in the middle of our courtship. So it's
It's not going too hot. I'm kind of disappointed. Uh, I thought I'd have a lot more
You know luck, but you know, sometimes it's not meant to be
I'm just trying to find my mr. Right, okay
I just want to have puppies
Oh, let's go this way
Okay, I'm getting closer
usually
Oh, I'm just gonna fall asleep
It's just easier that way. I don't feel like
Running all over and then I'm gonna run by them
Anybody any men?
Nobody wants me bro, why don't we get the option to a dopa cat? Nope, I didn't mean to cut myself off
I'm not a spinster. I'm only two years old
I
Will travel across the land
searching for wine
Something something something something
and find a mate inside
Is that a fucking cougar? What is that? Can I scare it off? Ron, bitch? Oh, no, I can't run away
Is he gonna chase me? Oh, no, it's just shown, okay
Ain't nobody gonna match my freak
What the fuck was that? But we just got scared for me picking up a box
I just no boy wife. I just want a boy wife
Let's try this to box me
All these a cougar would destroy me probably
I have all these Korean snacks. Oh
You're just supposed to be spicy. I'm pretty good. Wow like sweet and spicy
What the fuck there's a drink in here I didn't even notice
I'm gonna drink that now
You have a saddle before your ovaries dry up. No, Charlie. Thank you for soup. I don't say such things
No, I will have puppy
Why do I hear something like wind blowing?
My no, I don't see my biological stroke is ticking
Oh
It's like apple soda, that's pretty good Koreans you got good snacks
I just want a trad wolf wife, no boy wife
It's tabaki, I don't know how to pronounce it
Hi, who me? No, don't go for my headphone
I don't know it's a Korean snack
It's like a puffy right rice flake rice cracker
Spicy and sweet soothing
Twink boy wife. Yeah, I'm not I'm not having the puppies. He's having the puppies
Female wolves
Maybe I'll get a girlfriend instead. Maybe this maybe I'm just meant
Oh my god, that's scary. Miss morrigan tipped four dollars and 20 cents
Sheebie needs a male wolf male wife to pump a litter in her asap
Excuse me
What
The purple litter in me
Oh my god
I'm intimidated
Boomi you're sitting right in front of my screen I can barely see when they were fat ass
That way
I
Rabbit that doesn't multiply doesn't add up
I'm thinking that I have to be like in the territory to get to get men's
Yeah, give me your best riz tips chat come on harem
Oh
I clicked yes
That's a fox
Oh
Hello boys you have a cool collar on um, they all think I'm pretty hot
Wait is that 12 18? Oh, no, it's not I was gonna say
You have a cool collar which means the doctors look after you and you're probably more focused on and maybe like we can like be a family vlog channel
I'm kidding four years old. Are they all four years old?
What's that why do you have more diversity, but you're like a darker wolf
Maybe the pelt's different
Did you just leave? Okay. Well, I will
Do something just give me a moment. I'll roll all that
Phantom pack
I
Who want me?
Phantom pack
It's like
They're like the in the atoma game. They're like the golf triplets or like the brooding
They're the cullens
And I'm like, oh the phantom it's the phantom pack
I
Don't know if I don't know if they're interested in me. They're kind of just
You guys want to hang out or you guys want to chill you guys interested?
Oh
You like me you just you just jumped up mr. 806
All right, let's get the show on the road. Let's play about let's do it
Nice belly nice impressive. What about you bro over there?
Uh a little bit of I'll do a little know a thorough little play bow at you. What about that? How you how you feel?
how you feel about that bro
Guys, what do I tell them? How do I how do I talk?
How do I talk?
What should I say you said you would give me riz?
You deserve me. You said you would give me Riz ideas. What am I supposed to say?
He's he's bold. He's in my face, bro. He's he's he's about it. I don't know 806 could get it
Howl at the moon, I don't know I don't talk to guys
Immediately fold smell their butts. Okay. Okay. I'm gonna I'll sniff his ass. I'm gonna sniff his ass. Oh
He liked me
I
Drink it's it's called Demi soda apple flavor and it's a Korean beverage
And I'm dying
It's very tasty though, honestly 805
You know five come come at me, bro
You know, you don't have a lot of diversity, but it's okay
He's a phantom
Danny phantom Demi already one of them is just he's not about it
He's about it though, you know five and we have really high diversity. Oh, you want to howl together? I'll howl with you
And he's a sick color he's nice. He's a nice nice fur nice nice coat. He's a white booty
interesting, oh
He's he's showing a little bit. What is on his belly?
It's like a tee does he have abs?
Oh
But he really liked me
He's he's waiting for me. He's just like please please madam pick me
Let's see how how dominant can I get with you?
But you still tall you're still standing tall and proud. Let's do it mean you. Oh
You're sweet you're sweet
Fuck off 805 you're too late
It's mean 806
All right
Here's your trial run. Mr. 806. You were just a phantom of me
I hope you don't mind my floppy ears. Let's go. Let's go find something to eat together
He stood on business or would you get that collar? It's a radio collar. So it's like he gets tracked
And a lot of these wolves are based off of real wolves by the way, so there's probably a
Wolf that looks like you know, whatever the fuck and
Has a radio collar, which is pretty cool. Oh, we want to howl together you can howl together
Our pups will look just like us cuz we're literally the same coat type except a different shade actually no you're kind of gray and brown I
like it
sassy
Don't be lazy though. It seems like he might be a little lazy
But I don't mind lounging around the they know the woods every once in a while. Let's go. Let's find some
food
Where did they go? I went this way?
What is that sound? Oh, why did I lose the set?
Big piney
Is the dude where are all these girlies coming from are you also dispersal wolf come here, bitch
These are my boys you don't get my boys
Yeah fucking we're killing her
These are my fucking boys
White and you right in the fucking coochie sick. Um, oh, he's good
Can we kill a wolf all that?
My man my harem just kidding. I wouldn't I swear I'm not this jealous
Come here
Come here girly pop fine
Good job, honey, where'd he go always right there nice job sugar tits. I'm really proud of you
I'm I'm not submissive
Why am I I don't why am I submissive I don't want to be submissive. I'm not a sub
This fucking bitch is coming back for more
Why do you stick on his tail dominant on me? Are you are you trying to dom me right now bro?
I am
Oh, I can squeak
What is it why can I only do
I am the alpha
Yeah, you better howling. Oh, he's all close to me. That's kind of sweet. We should nap. Let's snap. You're right
We should res address
Is he the one I think he might be the one guys
He thinks you look fertile
Why am I submissive I don't want to be submissive
Oh
Okay, the test is
Can he hunt with me?
And there's a grizzly nearby um
Where is the sense drifting from
I
Handsome
I'm trying to find I don't want it grizzly
Oh, it's right fucking there. Uh, okay this way sweetheart. Don't kill yourself. Are you good? Are you on me? Okay, you are
um
It all comes down to when we share our first meal together, you know, it's very important
Uh, if I could just find a fucking pack that'd be great
There's a little bar next to my head and if that fills blue then I think we officially become mates
Oh, we're at the border. Uh, we can't cross the border. This is oh am I in the corner of the map?
Where the fuck are we?
Oh look at him. He's just like hey
All right, let's go into their territory to be honest
Oh
He's like right with me. You're so good. You look nice in my sent vision. Okay, let's go
You smell anything mister
You miss the first guy. Oh, I'm at the border again. Where the fuck am I running to?
Oh
Where should I go this way? I can't tell where my arrow is pointing. Okay, this way
Oh, they're coming closer to the males again, I guess we just went into a fucking circle
sweetie
Uh, we might run into your brothers, but don't worry. We won't make it weird
We're just looking for food. We don't have to make it a thing. I picked you
Let's just see if you live up to my expectations
What the
Why why is there scent coming? Oh, I'm literally on the edge
That's because I'm like why is this because the edge is right here
No, I went in the wrong direction
Oh my god, okay, we need to go up
I'm beginning to think she'd be as high. I mean, it's I'm really not
I just I don't think I am is that a moose
Why can't I smell the moose? It's right in front of me
Uh, I don't think we can
Talk talk hunt a moose. Boomi. Can I help you sweetheart? You're like right in front of my screen again. What's up?
And you're trying to sniff um
My soda can that made me burp like a motherfucker. He just stepped and kicked my mouse
What's happening now? I lost my orientation boomi
Okay, this way
Mr. Mr. Boomerton, can you oh perfect. Let's see. Oh no, did I crash? Okay, I didn't
Boomi I can't see past your head
Am I too slow?
Why are these deer so fucking fast?
Oh, you broke off your mind
Oh
I'm too slow for this shit. Oh those elk. I don't know. They just came into the pack. Oh, let's see if I can
You could help honey
You could help
Why are they so fast? Why was I able to catch up to them before now? I can't
Okay, do we need to stalk them? I think we do
Let's stalk
I can't
Stalk this far away. Why are you just looking at me like that? He's just like what the fuck are you doing?
Why are you staring at me? Oh, we can't keep his eyes off of you guys
You see that
I
Like how a bear just walked through the herd with its baby and they didn't even fucking leave for that
Okay, we're getting a little restless go speed up
What what this one that one that one that one that one are they so fast?
I
Feel like I was faster. Oh, was that an elk?
Who are you?
That's a little bit bigger
It's like these random other deer are coming out of nowhere to join this herd and it's quite confusing
Guys I can't run them down
Are you sick? Come here sickly
Oh
Oh, what the fuck it just ran into me and hurt me
We need we need to circle circle
Yeah, oh my game is frozen
Oh, I'm trying to bite your ass. It's like locking onto the wrong thing. Okay. It's okay circle circle circle
Oh, I'm going too fast
Go
My game is like slowing down
You're like not really helping that much
Okay, uh, oh we gotta go
Oh
We should leave
My guy you gotta help Rosa Narmard. He's so he's not even he's being a baka daddy. Oh god
We gotta go they're gonna kill us. Okay, it's fine. We're almost out. We're almost out. We're almost out
Some badass guitar riffs they got going on. Okay, we're good
We just need to eat food together though I can slow down
Where are you? I don't know my game is lagging suddenly
Fuck off, bro. We can howl too
Oh
He has a handsome howl
Oh shit, it's ops. No, he just a little play about but I we don't have time for that
Sweetie we need to find food
Oh
We're back in their territory, but it's fine
Maybe I don't know
I kind of don't want to why is the game? Oh, no. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. No, no, no, no
We gotta go we gotta go
No, we got it honey, honey save me. No, they're killing him
No, this is not how I wanted it to end
We gotta go honey, honey, no
Honey, we can't fight them. Come on. Oh, no, my camera's fucked. Come on, honey
We got we're almost out we're almost out sweetheart. Is he is he good? Come on come keep running
No, come on. Come on. Come on. We gotta go. We gotta go. I don't want to leave you
I hope he can like get out. Usually I think they'll just chase. Okay. He's fine. He's fine. He's fine
Oh my god, he's half health like me
I don't
Wait, what the fuck where are we? Oh, I'm going the wrong way. Okay
We're safe we're safe we're safe we're safe. Are you okay? Are you good?
I'm gonna look you. Are you all right? Thank you for sticking with me. He had my he had my back
Honestly, you're really real for that
Let's take it now
He's he's the right to die he like threw himself into the fire for me for that one
He's a real one. I think I think 806 is the one guys
I
Think we need to catch two elk together though
What am I just flipping around awkwardly little play bell you like that
Are you
Yeah
You like the you like my little little tail wag. Look how my tail does it
Wait, are you taller than me? Oh, he is. I thought we were like the same size, but he's a little bit bigger
It's all right
All right, let's find some food. I'm going too fast
Okay, I'm gonna
We're going this direction
What's that
smell abandoned wolf den
interesting
Moose
We need to eat a lot of fucking grizzly nearby. I don't know why all the grizzly just chilling around
If I find a den can we just like make puppies in
All I smell is moose and grizzly bear. What's going on here?
Are we gonna because I know we'll try to we'll fucking die if we try to take down a moose
We don't have pups with us
That are like at least half grown, you know, you know what I'm saying
Where am I going? I don't want to run into a territory on accident
Oh, okay, this deer nearby it's a deer nearby
See if we can catch up to her maybe
I lost a scent
There she is
Let's take her down
Speed up
Get her
Get her ass
We're catching up. We're catching up. We're catching up cut her off
I'm bringing up the rear
I'm on her six. I'm on her six
Almost there
I've got you in my sights
Wearing her down in biting range going for it
I'm on her ass bro. Why doesn't it let me bite this thing? I'm literally on her
I'm starting to get tired. There we go
Sweetie, where are you at? Sweetie, I need assistance
Sweetie, I need assistance
Sweetie, Sweetie
Get her
Good job. Good job, Sweetie. Keep get her
I'll bite her
armpit. You get her throat
I can't see what's happening
There's a tree in the way
Nice job
We did it. Yeah, I see mo we did it. I'm trying to eat
Oh, he also took his food
Hey, why are you taking your food away?
What's up with that dude? Do you not want to eat with me?
Okay, you use okay
Oh
Seems like we both just take a hunk of meat. Okay, I'll eat with you over here. Did you like that here?
I don't know. I guess it's different with you 806 because you like you like fought for me, you know like
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
I would like to eat
It's not letting me eat
I'm just taking meat chunks
Okay, he kind of ate a lot
Oh, buddy left me some that was nicer you
Can I please eat this? Okay
I'm full. Okay. Um, well that was fun
Can I uh, I'm not submissive
confident
Okay, I guess I'm
How you doing honey, oh he fucking whipped around he was like, yeah, but
You want you want some of this you want some uh, I'll give you a smooch for that
um
Oh, he went to go eat. I was just like what the fuck
honestly relatable
um
Like I was just meat chunks around you know what I play
I love that chunk there. He saw me. He appreciates my cooking
He appreciates my cooking
All right. Oh my god
I'm trying to like fucking do anything. Okay. There we go
He's so enamored. He's just staring at me. He's like I can't even do anything
Oh, I love that for us. Is your health low?
I'm gonna take a nap. All right, I'll nap with you. You can take a little nap. Oh time freezes in photo mode. I'm good on that
I didn't mean to growl. I'm so sorry
Um, please don't take that the wrong way come back
Oh, his name is gone. I'm a little confused. Are you leaving me? Are you still with me?
Are you still my mine?
Oh, he got shy after I gave him a sniff. That's kind of cute
He's he's kind of handsome. Can I give you a kiss?
I don't like that noise. I'm not a fan of that noise
Oh
No, I I'm only gonna
Oh, he's in spread and perhaps my strength and haunting skills. Yeah
Guys, what should we name him?
He's so subby
What should we name him?
We got a maid
Okay, okay bussy baron
Okay, okay, what was it give me a caller
Is
The red bionicle
Trying to fight
Busy baron black fang
Oh the book. No, that's why fang
Guys have terrible colors that you're coming up with
Green give me some unique colors like how chartreuse was i'm chartreuse kooch. So
The fang bringer of puppies
Aluminium vermillion
Okay, and let me add one more
All right, what's his name guys
What's his name
So
Bionicle
Seems like vermillion knot is winning
Do made expensive infinite knots
Wait isn't vermillion red fuck
All right
Looks like vermillion silver knot is fine. I'm a bionicle knot. We'll do that. We'll we'll have a little
Ca what's it called? Ca how about alexander
That's normal name. Um
Your name is mr. Wolf covar rubius and you said alexander
Cross over compromise. Thank you vermillion bionicle knot
Uh, we're gonna call him wait, how many oh I can make it as long as I want perfect, uh, okay
I
Bionicle
I saw that I meant to smell hair, but not not pharum sounds pretty cool
Not harem
He has a
Alden ring name
What
I
I wanted to do a whole thing and wouldn't let me do it
I wanted to call bionicle. Oh, okay, I like that
I
Bionautical perfect
Bionautical
The vermillion
Bionautic fuck I need to space
The harem
The the bionautical oh my god, I almost dropped my controller
I'm just gonna call him the bionautical. Why is that I look like an L?
You and your main are forming a new family a family snapshot has been saved you give you the family tree in the main menu
Oh, no, we're gonna establish our fucking territory. How about that?
That I bionautical three
Okay, we need to find a den use the iconator compass to find it. Okay
Winter has arrived snow no blankets the slopes of amethyst mountain bring grass beneath it
All curds are migrating down into limar valley and search for winter raising grounds follow them down if you want to keep eating
You and your mate are expecting pups. You must now carve out your own territory here in the lower slopes of amethyst mountain later
But for just for the pups are born in two months. You must find a good den within your territory
Other packs are also expecting puppies. So they're establishing and expanding their territories, too
You need to make sure you claim enough space to create a safe buffer to protect your vulnerable pups from them
Okay
potential den sites
potential dens face south to catch what the spring sunshine must turn out about great
I'm an area by marking it
Okay, fifth I need 15 hexes
Okay, uh, cuz like
Oh, we can eat this meat. Not that meat. The meat's still good
I won't even let me interact with it. Um, sorry. I'm locked on you. Oh, you're like covered in snow
I'm covered in snow
Okay
So limar
They're gonna be down here
So we should probably work our territory around this area. So I want to
aim
over here
Like right over here
near. Yeah, like this area
Spawn rock
And like because just because of the elk is all going to be down here
And there I think you probably steal their shit
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, can I set a marker?
How do I make a marker?
Add custom marker, please. I would like a marker. How do I add a marker? How do I add it?
Is that
Is that just how do I fucking?
How do I get to how do I make the fucking marker?
I just want to make a destination
Uh destination final destination right here
I
Can't do anything with it though
I wish I could just like mark it like it's fucking Elden Ring, but I think it's just it's not that's not what it is
Okay, I think I'm misinterpreting what that means sex alive
Sorry, I'll just start sex alive
Okay, we ran into a lot of these wolves
Who do we kill moved elsewhere with mate?
All right
Shanks, let me aim myself in the right direction. I think it's this is this way. Oh, I can eat this now
I'm nom nom deli. So
Coyote
Let's go up here
Oh, there's a nearby den site too. Is that the den? No, that's just a rock
I
Want to get a little bit closer to the Lamar. Yeah
For a
Because I bet I'll have run into a den on the way there and dens are so irritating to find
I remember searching for like an hour when I was younger trying to find a den
And it was just like really weirdly like how they
Helped you because they use ascent markers for everything and you could never tell which direction shit was in
Okay, we're gonna slide down this hill
Wait, hold on. Let me just make sure. Yeah, we're good. I don't want to slide down into enemy territory and get fucking stuck
All I see is whiteness
It is a absolute blizzard out here. Okay. It was supposed to thunderstorm and it hasn't
I can't what's happening
Is is it not gonna rain today? Why do we have a thunderstorm warning if it's not gonna even rain?
I wanted it to thunder either thunder
Okay, where are we close just go a little bit angle. Yeah
I want to get right up to their hexagon
Although it's gonna be such a bitch to maintain the territory territory because it's a ridge right there
It's fine
As far as there's like no fucking dens in the area
Do you mean what are you gonna name your children? I don't know. We'll have to see how many puppies
I have and if they even fucking live, you know
Look, he's just happy to be here. Okay, let's calm down a little bit over here
Why there are so many wolves nearby
Okay
Our territory I'm gonna go over here a little bit more
Is that a bird?
So I want a piss it's pissing time
Market to boost the claim
Okay, cool
Let's go a little bit over here
We're gonna piss everywhere guys by nautical such a boy wife. He's such a good. He's such a good boy wife
Okay, I'm still in my territory. I hate that our territory is like yellow colored. I wish I could make it something else
I really want to be up against this lake because like fresh water. That's where they go, you know
I'm like literally on the edge of my own territory
Okay, there we go pissing time pissing time
There we go, there's another one
Yeah, I feel like killing a fucking coyote right now or fox whatever that was
We all matches all the pissing. You're right. You're right
Um
Should go let's see
I could probably claim some of their territory because it's weak
I wonder if I will be able to piss on somebody else's territory
Speed up. I was actually already going max speed awkward
What a beautiful winter day, uh, what the fuck honey help
Oh
Is that a fucking rabbit you you want some of that you can have it all you handsome are you hungry
Not you're good. All right
I'll eat. I'll eat. I'll eat the hair then
I know power move. I'm pissing everywhere. This is my domain
You
Come on, can I please cross over already?
Take take over his packs find their scent posts
Oh
interesting
So I literally have to find the scent post in order to claim it for myself. That's dumb
Okay, maybe I'll just focus on doing my own hexes then let's just pee here
To pee right next to this fucking tree
Cool should have been more strategic on where I peed but it's fine
You just try to pee next to a landmark so I can remember where the fuck it is
Oh, I'm like right on the edge of both our territories, huh? All right, let's keep going this way
We're gonna have to break into their territory and steal their elk
Oh
We're we're good on food right now. So
Let's see. Let's piss next to this big rock
Nope, this is already our territory. Um, let's piss next to this
Where should we piss because I'm at the come and read new these markers
Where am I?
Fossil forest
Fossil forest is like
In a really bitchy place so I kind of don't want to mark over here
Because climbing hills is such a thing
But it seems like I have to
Piss next to this rock
We piss maxing we are maxing our piss for everybody to know
All right, cool. Let's get this hex. Let's get this hex
Okay, I guess I just go straight around this rock
Damn, this is gonna take fucking forever, bro
I keep thinking these are wolves, but it's just a fucking branch looks like the back of a wolf
At least I can climb up this hill. Uh, not that well. Nope, never mind
All right, oh
Please please let me climb up. Okay. Thank god. Um, this is a nice rock to piss on
Where am I?
We're almost there. Look at that beautiful sunset
Wow, anyways, let's find a rock to piss on
Go these look at all those new growth
We're almost out. Yeah
Might have to sleep soon
Look at the sunset pookie binautical
Okay, uh
Where are the rocks for me to piss on?
Oh my god, I'm making myself fucking dizzy
I might go normal speed is that a rock to piss on? Yes, it is
It's just easier for me
You're not gonna help me piss dude
You're tired. I'm tired too. Should we nap here? Let's let's do a little nappy poo
Where are you going? He's like, oh, I thought we were gonna go do something. All right. I guess I'll stay in with you
Look at us even
The moon go down. All right, cool. Does that like change anything? Sick. Oh, they expanded. What the fuck?
Are you serious? I shouldn't have slept. I was really going in this fucking direction. Okay. Um
We're taking over that fucking hex because they're not I feel like
I feel like
This is like very hard
But this game was supposed to be easy
Okay, we're pissing here. We're taking this over
Can I howl?
Oh wait, I have to find their set marker in this hex. That's what it is
Hmm, where is their set marker? That's our pack. Do I get to name my pack?
How am I supposed to find this fucking thing?
Cougar
Rescue Creek Wolfpack
Hmm
Yeah, it's probably this way then
Oh, wait, no, what were they going into my pack territory? Oh, they were
Fucking cunts
We gotta teach them a lesson
Oh, that's a cougar nevermind. I thought it was a wolf. Don't worry about it
I'm using I better been just passing through
All right fine
Going back up here. Can you find this fucking set marker?
You're turf nah, they're having fucking like gang moors except it's pack territories pissing time
Nope, I went I pissed in the wrong square
All right
I'll piss in the next hexagon gotta keep them separated
Come out and I'm thinking of come out and play like
Warriors come out and play
All right one. Yeah
Oh
Where's their fucking scent marker? Oh, there it is
Oh, a perfect stripe by a fucking rock love it. We're pissing here
Are we being attacked? Oh, no, you're just making more noises
Get fucking wrecked dude this is our spot
I didn't mean to do that. Um the binautical
I
Just watched that the other again the other day and I was like, oh this movie's so fucking funny. It's just great. Okay. Let's go over here
She'll define a fucking den I gotta fill up 15 hexes. Oh my god
Such a hard-working mother. I'm just I'm just running around pregnant doing all this shit. Can you believe that?
I
Don't wanna okay cool cool cool cool
How many dens are in a territory? I don't even know it's like two one
Is that a den over there that big ass tree my pee at that big ass tree
We're peeing at this cool ass tree
Oh, hell yeah, this is a perfect tree to piss on look at this cool ass tree to piss on
Amazing
Okay, then we'll keep going straight now
Just running in a circle
Not much to do
Really getting in the wolf minds that wolves don't leave in trees. It doesn't matter. It's a cool tree to piss on
As they fall down a fucking hill
We're going after this pack we're taking their fucking territory
It's like fucking jenga
I wonder if we can because again
When I played this game
When I was younger you could it was up to the point where you could have puppies and that was it and then they
It's either that you let them live or they died, but you couldn't like expand the pack after that
So if you can that's very cool to me
Oh that thing just fucking juked me. Um, we can probably piss anywhere right for this one
Where's a good spot to piss in this place I'm just trying to try to piss in a nice spot
I don't really think they left a set marker so I'm just gonna put it right here
Oh
Oh my god my ass hurts from sitting
How are you doing by an article?
You're peeing good job, bro. Good job. We're gonna we're bordering. Let's see this way perfect
We're going around the border
We're very strategic in our placement
We need we need strong borders for our family nice scenic view for the piss spot exactly
Let's see, where are we going?
Oh, I'm going the wrong way. I need to go this way. Nope
What how the fuck did I get turned around?
Okay, I guess it's this way then
I
Haven't seen one other den and I'm running all over the fucking place
That's an Oreo blizzard. Oh my god, sweetie. You want an Oreo blizzard?
Then nearby here we go. Oh, what the fuck? Oh, okay. We don't I don't want cougars near a den though
Where's the den
Over here that it
This fucking nope, that's just a cool ass rock. I'm gonna piss right here
I would rather not have a cougar near the den. Where is it?
So this nearby
Okay
Am I close I don't I know it changes color. Nope. I'm going farther away because it's like this
It's just like it's hot or cold and it's dumb
The hot and cold
Where is it then? Okay, I guess it's in this direction heading east
No, is this the den? I don't
This has to be it
No, damn I should have pissed at the top of this
Because it's turning orange like right over here
Where's the fucking den by nautical
There's no den smell
Oh
My god, this is it didn't take me a fucking bazillion years to find out where the fucking den is
Farther away. Yep. It's so this direction it's fucking cougar out of here
Why I don't understand what the fuck I just like fell down this cliff face if I go this way
Oh, it turned why is it only orange right here?
I don't
Is there supposed to be I feel like there's supposed to be one here. I don't maybe I'm supposed to fill up the thing
I don't know
There's two homeless puppies pissing everywhere
I have to find four dens
How am I supposed to get four fucking debt what?
You're actually fucked bro. You're actually fucked if you think I'm gonna find this shit when you're not even giving me the
Scent markers to find them. You're just giving me hot and cold
Stupid dumb shit. I don't care anymore. I'm gonna focus on the hexes
Come here
You hungry here you can have it. Well you bro take a bite
You want it?
Can I see something can I tell him to eat? No, okay
Family's not gonna last winter if we can't do this bro
I'm going the wrong way. There we go. That's better
There's four densites you have actually got to be out of your mind
I don't ever I know I hope acts because I remember doing like this
It was I think it was like three or two densites when I was younger
But it was such a pain to find them because like they weren't obvious
Anything like that giant fucking rock would be obvious, but it wasn't. Um, is there any nice thing to piss on around here? No
No, no pissable items. No pissable scenery. Okay, I guess I'll just piss in the middle right here
There's this dead tree. How about that?
Cool. All right, let's uh
I could go for those hexes in the corner, but I'm not going to right now
See yeah, I'll go for
These hexes over here
I feel like I'm playing a really bad chest chest
Love the tune you get for peeing on something I love the sound
the the fucking
game
sounds
In music it's just so great
It's a great pissable rock
Oh going the wrong way
There we go
That's a great pissable rock
Too close
That rock right there
It's just gonna be it. Nope still in the territory. What the fuck? Oh wait, it's like right near it
Oh, okay
We'll piss right near it
Let's go buy nautical
This again
I need to find a set marker for this one
That's doom
At least there's like food around
I feel like my field of view is so fucking narrow that I can't even see where shit might be
I'm gonna piss
Sick, okay, I guess I just couldn't piss in the other spot before
Nice all right, we stole that from them and then we're just gonna go up here
Fuck is up with the music
Is there somebody nearby I don't
Why is there boss music
You
Already
That was pretty ominous your field of view is worse than that. Honestly the field of view in this game is horrible
Am I too tired? Oh, I am too tired doesn't fucking let's go to sleep, bro
Great, I bet they're gonna get more territory when we wake up
Oh, he hatched closer to me. That's really sweet
Oh, she's asleep, let's move
Oh, they fucking this is so annoying to maintain
Am I gonna have to be pissing everywhere?
Oh
Dead nearby. Oh, is this a dead? Nope. It's gone. You know, I already lost it. Where is it?
I said dead nearby. Where? Which direction?
Where
Where is she
I'm gonna piss on this ridge. No, I can't climb it
We're pissing on top of this thing
Okay, we got that they stole that one from us the absolute bitches
I need 15 how am I supposed to do that?
I'm queen of the world easy to maintain with the bigger pack a hundred percent
That's that's great sweetie, but we need to find
There's a moose is that an elk? There's moose
It's moose, okay
Dead nearby where where is the den?
This way
The first one I see I'm probably just gonna legit grab
White warm we're getting warmer we're getting warmer we're getting warmer
What are you doing
What the fuck
We need to get this why was this damn it oh fuck then nearby I don't care anymore
Trying to find this damn stupid den
I'm making myself dizzy
Drink more water nah now we're gonna drink a water
We're staying vigilant that's what we're doing
I'm actually gonna have a conniption where where am I okay might as well go towards the inside
I
Feel like this song should be in like red dead redemption
No, I didn't mean to go that way. Oh, I'm running all over the place
Oh
Damn it
We're gonna distract it because I'm trying to get food den den. How's there not a den over here?
Den
We're done
We're done there's a perfect little area for a den
Fuck
Tell me there's all these natural things whatever
Dan can't you sneak up on them? I that's true I could but I'm impatient
I
Don't tell me there's a fucking time
I can eat this what
Can I
Yeah, look what I got I got a fucking you want this bro you like this shit
Fuck sticks I got an elk antler
Anyways, I forgot there's also like humans in this game you can like come across humans and steal their sheep
remember when that
Uh extension came out the dlc came out. I fucking lost it
large food
Speed up get them get them bionicle. I know you're hungry bionicle. We gotta get them
Um
Fuck oh what I'm trying to look on this one
Oh, are you all gonna attack me because I will bite you
Ha ha
Oh perfect. Oh wait. No, I was gonna piss up here
Anyways, oh my god, I'm going too fast
Um, num, num, num, num. Oh, he's eating with me. Okay. I'm full. Uh, let me howl to mark it
Although animals will probably take it
Pretend I'm a unicorn
The tutorials say they face south so look from the north. Oh, it's a good point
Oh my god, why is it echo one place and then
Now I need to run over here fucking quickly
I'm pee over here
I'm gonna fall down this cliff
Oh my tail go
Go bionicle. I'm like trying to go faster and the camera just changes
Can I
Can I please
Can I please not do this? Oh, okay
Hi Fiya. What's up little girl?
I didn't mean to howl, but I guess that works
Our new nope that doesn't do it
I pee anywhere for this one because I'd rather just feel like I pee every pee anywhere
You just stinker. Yeah, it's a fucking stinker piss
I will piss so much too soon
Okay, I feel like I thought I would have to go and piss in the same spot, but it seems like you don't have to
Yeah, hi. She's just staring at me
Yeah
Taking this bunny with me
Fiya, can you please not chew on my cables? Thank you. Ah Fiya. Look what you've done
Hey, where am I going?
I want to claim this entire inside area
Hello little girl, would you like a pet picture, you know, you know Betty
She's like desperately trying to go into my lap and I'm like girl
Oh
Why are you so snuggly she's such a snuggly girl lady
Okay, where am I? Okay, we're almost there
Almost fucking there
Thank you. Hello, welcome in
Oh, fuck. I was not even paying attention. There was a fucking bison in front of me
Okay, it really doesn't matter which hacks I go into
Look at these mises I'm gonna piss right next to them to assert dominance
Wow, that's great that a den is nearby
Why are you talking to Fiya? Oh, yeah, was that Boomi?
Um, what?
Okay, I need one more fucking hex
Am I going the right way? Okay
Rock piss in time. Oh my god
Cat lost it
Boomi's laying in the bed and Fiya wants to lay in the bed with him
Very cool. And then Boomi just pushed her off my desk
Pop maxing is going coming along slowly
Okay, I'm running around the rabbit in my mouth
What what are you doing?
Why are you freaking up? Hi Boomi
You're just an epi boy. You're so you're bigger than this bed now. Holy crap
Hey, I mean, you're a new boy. You could just feet right in you. You know you're two beings
Are she break? I don't know I heard something crash
She's like I think she's trying to jump up on something. It just didn't work out
Let me have a munch. Thank you
Okay, I filled up 15 hexes
I must have at least 15 hexes at this time
What the fuck
Why is this on easy and it's more difficult
I have to find the densites. Oh actually just yeah, I'm gonna pass out right here
Oh
Okay, it doesn't mean walk in front of my screen mister. Yeah, you can sit there. That's fine. Listen on my keyboard
um
Which way the fuck is this thing?
Come on by on a call
It is probably should be I'm not running at full speed all the time Boomi is staring at my wolf on my screen and trying to bap it
Then nearby Boomi, can you find the den? Can you not play with my wires though sweetness?
I
Think you're right. Whoever said dens always face south
Um, I feel like if I went back on the opposite direction, I'd be able to find it. Boomi. I can't see
I'm gonna let you get down. Can you
And so can you move?
Can you get down?
I
Please
Beggin you bro. Thank you. Boomi the den sniffer
Come on, come on, come on. I want I'm just like it's gonna I wish it didn't fade so fast like
The um
Why'd you just place your paw on my hand?
Boomi, what's up, dude? Do you want to be held? What do you want?
Come here
Oh big boy. Oh, you're so big
Hi
You're gonna shit
You're just hanging out
You're so warm
Hi
He's like sitting on my lap like he's a kid
He just sits like a woman
Boomi's trying to tell me the secret den location
You're trying to tell me the secret den location
No
He just got a fucking limp in my arms. Okay. Um, here let me put you in the bed. Oh my god, you're so heavy
He's also really interested in my headphones because he wants to play with them
No, you cannot have go away. You also just took my headphone out of my ear
Okay, I didn't mean to sit
No, it's not the most depressed. All right. There's one fucking hex. Yeah one
I feel like the hexes should last longer than when I fall asleep. They're not just fucking gone because that's also just not realistic
This game isn't realistic enough
Oh, I'm going the wrong fucking way. Okay, almost there
The house is what boomi the cat is this house is people no boomi is bumi
For because he's the king of umashu. I'm just gonna fucking pee anywhere
Okay
Okay, let's go south
Let me just
Then nearby
I wish I would just show up in a marker
I lost it already this way because wait
I
Yeah, this is the right color
At it
Please be a den. No, it's just a fucking rock. Um, I face the south
I
Feels like it should be like right over here the snow is getting in my eyes
This oh, it's just another big rock. It's not a boner. It's a rock. It's a rock over here
Am I getting clenope it turned? Okay over here
Guys I'm not going crazy right like what it's supposed to then discover what the fuck
Oh, what?
How the fuck am I supposed to see that this is just a pile of fucking snow, dude
What
Okay, because I'm like how am I supposed to find any dens and I'm looking for like like a pile of sticks or rocks like in
The form of a den shape
I guess because that's what it looks like in the game like before when I played it
it was just like usually
Usually looks like this and you would turn on the other side and then there's like a little hole in this and that's where you
Would have the pops and shit. Okay. Well, let's find others. I guess and pee on the way
Um
Because I'm closest to this one over here. I'm just gonna go
Start global warming. Hello, welcome in
We are wolves
Because I'm gonna play that song if anybody clips me can you play the we are wolves?
We run as one or whatever
However, fuck it goes
I'm gonna piss in your fucking thing
Ah, bitch I got
Okay, now I have just have to look for uneven patches of snow on the ground that'll make it a lot easier that's for sure
You
Okay as many hexes in a short term as possible
Okay
All right, gotcha
I don't like how they took that red. I don't feel like hunting for their marks
So we're gonna look for the dens the dens are the priority. We're just gonna run around
And look for dens
This is literally
I didn't think we'd take this long to just pop max. It's it's pop slow right now. It's pop. We're pop minning
Where am I
I
Can I pee
Um, yeah, it's actually good that I'm I can just run through and piss on places
But then I have to make sure I'm in the right fucking hex to do it
This is a dumb game mechanic
I will tell you that dead nearby. All right dead nearby guys
Keep an eye out for weird shit. Give me this fucking rabbit. I'm hungry. Yo
You want that I wish I could like feed him
Where's the den where's the den am I in the right spot? I don't know. Okay again
Um, oh, okay, okay, I'm just gonna walk slowly
This is so stupid
Okay, we're getting warmer
We're very warm
Do you guys see any misshapen snow on the ground?
No, it's over here
I don't is that one
Oh, see it looks like this shit
Oh, okay, see this looks like an actual fucking den
I got a den max for the pep max. That's exactly right. Yeah, turn on a fucking late max. I can't reach
Now that's a den
That's a den if I've ever seen one
Oh, there's thank yous over here
There is really is green tea. What is this?
It looks like this isn't in English. It looks like seaweed popcorn
But it smells like caramel, but it looks like it has seaweed on it. What is this?
It tastes like peanut brittle. No, it tastes like caramel corn. Oh, it's pretty good
Look rice puffs
It's in Korean so I can't read it
Oh, it's like lightly caramelized rice puffs with like little like little burnt pieces like a marshmallow
Hey, that's pretty good
Oh shit, there's another high chew in here
Yeah, whoever drives this is Elder Scrolls fan
Maybe you never know
I want you on this high too
I'm tangled up in wires
Okay, I am pretty tired
I wish I could just make that the den because it looks badass
What a shot I take a picture
Gorgeous
Hi boomie
Okay, let's see the fucking damage Jesus Christ this purple pack is taking over holy shit
Oh my god
I need to steal some hexes back. Oh my god Jesus
Um
Let's see I should probably go
This way towards that one
Right it's coming out right in purple or fucking in it to win it
Speed it up
Look at him look at me lovingly as we run. He's not even watching where he's going
I'm happy I picked
Vynautical, you know
He's a good guy
Made am I in the
I want to make sure I go down to this one first
I wish there was like a den
I wish there was like a den in each. Oh, no, that's fine little hex so I wouldn't have to worry so much
Jesus well actually I can cut down the middle between these
Why does it take me forever to cross into my own territory wait did I just go in the wrong direction? Okay, I know I did
Okay, I think I could piss
Okay, cool, that's great and then I can go up to this one make sure I'm going up though. No, I'm going down
Cool
Just got out you got to renew the markers bro
Atreides are getting their asses handed to them
Den nearby den nearby everybody slow down grab the wall
Is it this way?
Nope this way
Den nearby
Trying to find the direction
Color is not changing. Oh now it is. All right, we're getting a little warmer
Oh, we are on fire is it that over there? I'm gonna hope these let it be it
No, this is just a rock
Again, it's just a rock. Wait, how is this a den? Oh that
Oh, I see you see how hard this is how the fuck am I supposed to see that?
Okay, I already peed here can I pee again?
This is a good den site though
All right, I mean
This way yes this way
Bro, you fits in that. I don't know. It's like really hard to like to
Catch them because they're like in weird places. They don't they're not like immediately obvious or highlighted
I
Also might take a purple slot just because they're getting a little bit too frisky for me. There's another den nearby
What?
You're fucking with me. Where?
Where's the den?
Why am I suddenly now coming across all the dens?
Is
The right direction I can't really tell this is the right right nope. It's not about this way
Okay, is there gonna be one in the middle of nothing over here? I don't
I
Don't want a den so close to them. Hello. Oh, didn't I already discover this one?
What the are they all just deciding to show up? I don't I'm quite pissed
I
Don't think I want one on the edge of the territory why why have you just started some fries some chicken
I know he's not he's not pissing as much as I thought he would
Okay, we're we're pretty strong over here
Um
Oh
I need 14
All right, I'm taking this fucking one over here
Where is it?
Oh
Male dispersal moves. Here. Here. Here. Here. Here's your fucking marker. It's mine
In the center
Why am I getting an autosave? It's because there's moose right here. I don't care about the moose. I care about the piss
I go up here
Why can't I find?
What the fuck is this hex I buy an article
I
Know we're good
We weakened it but it doesn't seem that it wants to let us take it
Let me how much piss do I have in my body I can piss so much
There's me saying pissing. I don't want it
Hmm, I can't find their marker. So maybe it I don't do I just have to piss another spot
All right, I'm just gonna piss everywhere. How about that?
It just keeps doing the fucking noise, but it's not changing color and it should be because it's at 50%
There's no site sent marker
We're not really that hungry so I don't have to worry about that right now
Well, and now we're in their territory and I don't want to go that far
I thought I heard a wolf grow
This is stupid
Okay, so on this little baby tree. Let me take over this spot
This game about is like Russ. Yeah, you're literally just a wolf. You're not that's that's a little yet. You're just a wolf
And you hunt and you raise puppies. How the fuck did I get over here again? I went in the wrong direction
Pissing over here
I am piss maxing right now
Come here
Get him. I got him. I got him. We're eating good tonight, baby
We are eating good tonight by nautical. You're so great, honey. Keep it up
Oh my god, lovely. Oh, I didn't mean to fucking jump, but okay. Can I slow down?
Delicious you want some of this you're eating my ass right now, bro
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about. Oh fuck
Damn
And it sucks because we need to sleep
Okay, I don't have to eat um very good. Let me how
Mark the spot
It's impressively bad pathing
Listen
Trying my best out here look at this fucking little guy. It's a little little eagle hanging out
I'm wondering if I shouldn't
Be running as much but I don't really think stamina has to do with my exhaustion. It doesn't
Seem to be that much affected by it
I'm taking over this hex
I
The fuck is howling
Oh, it's the raiding and I'm pissing everywhere. Oh god high raiders. I'm peeing all over the place. Don't look
You can watch it's fine. Whatever you're into
How is the stream I knew you
No
I'm not a mom. I'm not a furry
I'm just being a wolf man
Peeler never been in the allocations
Oh my god, I'm waiting to class
Collapse from exhaustion
But hi raiders. We're playing wolf quest and I'm she be by the way if you don't know who I am if you don't then you're weird
um
And I'm pissing marking my territory with my husband the binautical
We're looking for another den so we can raise our puppies
Before winter. Oh look at that fucking elk and we can also hunt
I'm not that hungry though. So I don't have to hunt him but
It's a big fucking elk
Shall we get it?
I kind of want to show off for the boys. I kind of want to show off for the boys
Oh, he sees us. Fuck
Oh, maybe he doesn't
Keep sneaking honey. He's in love with me so much. He can't keep his eyes off me, but it's fine
We're stalking we're stalking
I'm bringing up his seven o'clock you got you get him
Get him honey, honey do something honey
Honey, please attack honey
Honey
Can you bite his ass?
Why am I doing all the work? Usually he's better than this
There we go. We got each leg
Oh
Why did you get injured?
No, we got him. Come on. We can finish him off
We can finish him off. Why am I my camera is all fucked up
There we go
Out it's fine
I brought my jog up ruse. It's okay. Don't worry about it
Taha you missed
Ground by the throat ground by the throat ground by the throat. We're getting him. We're killing him
It's all right. We're good
My mate is kind of being useless right now, but it's fine. Can honey stop looking? I should actually help
He's just so much in love with me
I
Also don't have a lot of stamina so I can't hold on to him that for that long. He's really just walking around
Okay, grab a leg
He's almost down. He's almost down. Come on
We almost got him sweetie get him
Finishing blow finishing kill get absolutely gacked
Grab you by the throat take you down get dragged
Actually bodied get mugged bro
Look at that. I got yeah fucking steak. You want some of this shit? You guys want this you want to bite?
That's that's how I do it. I'm a real alpha
You know
Not like these posers out here by a nautical is debating why he married me because he's like
Why did you put us in the situation?
Is it possible to get your wolf strong enough to one shot everything? I don't think so. Well, you can again you can scale stuff in here
I need to find wait
I need 15 hexes. Oh, I did find four densites. Um
Because you get like perks and shit, which I don't know how that works what perks you get
um, but
So far I have negative strength and negative health, but I have speed and stamina. That's why I'm fast as fuck when I run
Uh, I go really fast
Alpha she being her boy wife. Yes boy wife and girl boss. Is this a multiplayer? It is multiplayer
I I don't I haven't played multiplayer in a while when I remember playing
I think you kind of five people in it, but I don't I wonder if it's more now that you could do
Um, I have to sleep now
Bro, oh my god purple pack is fucking us so bad that we have to sleep
I think it's eight now. Oh that'd be sick
Guys want to play with me in wolf quest
I love by the time we wake up, uh, everything will be fucking gone. There'll probably be a bear next to us
I want to be surprised. Is there a bear?
No, all right
I'm running too fast
See the damage. Okay, it's not that bad. It's not that bad. We're fine
We are going to look how big the moon is over there
We're fucking yapping we're gonna go up and then across
What uh
Or all these coyotes just hanging out it's kind of weird. They're just like waiting for us to leave I guess
Or being chased by the coyotes, I don't
What the hell
I don't even know I don't they must
They're very loud
The alert girls from a pack. Oh that'd be fun. What's our pack? I don't even have a pack name
It doesn't let you name the pack. I think when I get puppies, I can name the pack
Okay, we're almost there
Let me have to find their fucking scent marker and take back the hexagon
I feel like I'm playing like
What is that game?
Strutego or fucking risk. I don't remember
Oh my god, strutego though
I remember playing that
Okay, we have to find the scent marker
So we got like smell a vision which is pretty cool smell a vision allows us to
Okay, where's their marker
Why do I smell a skull the fuck that's kind of weird
Um, we have to find their scent marker so we can write over it
I'm gonna piss right here
I
Don't even know what their strength is that
For the piss
Sellers of katana. Actually, yeah, it's that's more apt
I don't know how I don't see a marker. Wait, did I just see one?
No, I'm just fucking tripping
Because it's
What is that?
Oh, it's a carcass. I smell
Like what does the x stand for because usually it's like
It'll be a purple marker and they don't have a lot of colors in here just right here
Renew that then we're back in here
This is really just pissing simulator
Okay, we're taking this back though just good
So yeah, you can take stuff back by like howling peeing and just your presence there
We have to get 15 hexes at at least 50 strength in order for us to have puppies
Hi boomie
And I'm trying to take over this fucking hexagon because they stole it from me from before
I think if we go up this way we should be good
It's funny because I haven't seen any other wolves you think you'd see them like renewing shit
Boomy sweetie, what are you doing? It's like so she's sitting on my desk and staring at nothing
Oh my god purple pack stop being assholes
Something like this for for wild cats
Uh
What is that is it like two hearts? I think there is a game like this for cats and I forget because I used to play that one
too when I was younger
Oh, yeah, I think I peed on top of this or I wanted to last time
Yeah, this will be the scent marker spot. Let's fucking go piss
Too soon relax. All right, then we're gonna go up boomy sweetie. I can't see past your girth
Your booty's in the way
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, we pissed off this cool tree
That's right cool tree pissing
It's a sick ass tree. See this would be a den site and you have like a little den in here like come on
The opportunity was there. Okay, I did not
I'll even show my sun markers
Yes, excuse me. What my cat's food is going off
What was it straw? He said in a call a camera. Yeah, I was on the call
Um, she's like, you know who my favorite character is in your streams and I'm like who she's like your cat's food dispenser going off
And she's because it like I forget if you're like having a meeting around the time it goes off in the afternoon
and
What the fuck didn't I just mark that?
And um, it went off and like totally
Uh surprise everybody
Let me just cross into mine real quick
Perfect. I'm just gonna literally on the edge of glory just pissing everywhere
Am I done yet? Like did I beat the fucking?
I needed them at 50 50 strength. Oh my god
Okay, then I literally just have to go to the ones on the top and do that. Okay fine. Hopefully they'll let us finish
Because I'm tired of running around I've literally been running around peeing for like the last two hours
This is my least favorite part of this game is the hex
game mechanic
Because things should not run out after four fictional hours
When your wolf sleeps for eight
Go up here
And it takes such a long time to run across a hex
Need a dispenser as a cast
I thought you were finishing like hair in this week
So close
I can almost taste it
Release your inhibition
cool
That's cool. Okay, perfect and then I can just cross into this one. All right, I'm on the edge. Perfect
Perfect. Okay. You've established a good territory. I found several potential dents. You and your mate are truly a pack now
So give your pack a name or ask for suggestions
Don't include pack a name as that will be added automatically suggest a name rebel pack
Tofacious pack prowler pack that sounds creepy as fuck
Fang pack hope creek pack that sounds pretty cool actually
Overlook fossil forest sleet galaxy slit stone ayo
Woke up
Why do you give me slit stone twice? Pawsome
Hush, what are these fucking names pouncer pack? Why are they like tofacious so much?
Whitewater whitewater possum scar blizzard yogurt
Yogurt pack
The bum hunters pack pack his pack
I'm bringing piss pack
I'm bringing sexy pack. Okay. I think that's a good name
I think that's a great name
I'm bringing sexy
But except instead of back it's pack
Can I do a comma? No, I'm bringing sexy pack
Choose a den
Oh, fuck
You've established a territory in the slopes of anthos mountain
But remember you must maintain it even when your pups require all your time and attention great
Smaller your territory the more likely stranger wolves be tempted to come in and kill your pups great
It's most efficient mercury when hexes have dropped to 30 or 40 strength
Plane your hunting trips so you can mark hexes along the way
I don't think actual wolves have to deal with this
Find a den. Okay. I haven't gotten this far since I played the game a long time ago
So we'll see you see that twitter torrent of youtube or animations dancing to that song
Yes, I did. That's why I put in a sexy pack
I'm bringing sexy pack
yet
Your pups will be born soon and the snows begin to melt it's time to find a good dead site
There's no need to dig a new dent for yourself since there are many potential sites out there
Cool, cool, cool
How to find a den they look different now the snow is melted
Okay, now dens will emit float scents like before why didn't they do that before
Remember the dens are always in south facing slopes to catch as much as the spring sunshine. That's very cool. I didn't know that
Um, okay, so the they should already be marked for me
Show all dens. Oh, they're all down there. I'd rather have one up here are in the middle
I think I'm gonna try to find one towards the middle
I didn't mean to pee but that's fine
It's fine
I should probably
Yeah, let's go across
I'm gonna try to find a den up here. I want one in the middle of the hexes
So I can just go into a circle when I want to
It's pop max in time
Oh look at the bison they'll probably fucking kill us. I'm how am I going the wrong way?
That doesn't make any fucking sense to me
I
Don't wait I'll just piss here again
Thanks husband
Imagine you're just like an elk and you're just chilling with like hanging out with your herd
You see these wolves just run by and fucking piss everywhere then run away
I'm not going after them. I'm just trying to get to the hexagon. Please. Let me get to the right hexagon
Perfect
Cool, I'm not gonna bother with that one up top
Let's see
Although would be well
It's fine
Let's go down here. Although if I do do one of the dens at the bottom
I can literally probably just take out that entire corner for myself
But that would take so much fucking time. I'm not I'm not feeling that
Had I known the dens are all in this bottom part. I would have done that but they don't tell you that
Let's see. I want to find more dense. Okay. There's some over here. Well, well because they're far away
They're probably just showing up as a marker
Tell me there's no dens nearby
Tell me there's no dens around here in the center, which would be perfect for me
You fucking bitch
I
I'm bringing sexy pack. Did you just killed me? Sorry. What is
Oh, what the hell? I'm sorry
One two three four. Okay. I thought they were showing five for some reason
Is there another one no
Wow
I'm bringing sexy pack
Sorry, I'm just so proud of myself for that
Okay, it looks like I'll be have to be four. Oh dens nearby dens nearby
Where
Oh, we want to fucking sorry. You're in the middle of howling. Let's howl together
Is there pvp in this game? I don't know. I don't remember if you could ever like try to kill other wolves
This is dead nearby but like where
It's not changing color
Oh sit down this way
Oh seems like it
I don't see anything saying it's around here facing the south
I
Wanted one in the middle
There's not a lot of cover, but maybe that would make it easier to keep track of the puppies
Try to think of what's best for my children. Okay
Oh, we're close we're close. We're fucking close. Is that it?
Is rocket
Please let this big-ass rock be it
Yeah, yeah, uh, no
That's what the fuck bro
Saying it's like right over here. I don't fucking see anything
Oh
My god, I'm literally losing it
I bet it's next to a fucking tree that I just can't see
Is
This is this fucking tree it I don't fucking know is that it what is this
This is a wooded den the trees
How is more ground cover than open dens giving potatoes like cougars and faces to hide the attacker pups from
What do you mean what wooded cover
How
There's no wooded cover. What are you fucking talking about?
I can oh
What the hell are we gonna live in a dirt pile
Whoa, what the fuck
I don't want this den
I don't want that 10 10 is ugly
No, I don't want it
How do I kind of cancel I don't want this fucking dirt pile to be my house
I don't want the fucking dirt
Cuck dirt
Oh, I'll name it cuck dirt
I
Won't let me get out of this
Okay, I love the game last out of safe
Oh, oh, look at the little baby little fucking cougar bocats whatever they are
Okay, I don't want that to be my den I think um
I think I'm gonna look for the I like aesthetics I go to the nearest one
I
Let them one down here
Those coyotes are loud and annoying
I liked that tree one
Or the one in the rock was pretty good, but it'll be open for birds
I I don't think that was a factor the last time I played this game. You had to like worry about things
Now I have to find
Rettucar property. Wait, did they?
Oh, they did
Oh, it's whatever it's fine. It's not a priority right now. It's not a priority
What the fuck oh, let's go to the piss right here
Act so strong
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna mark it anyways
Okay, so there's a den right here. Am I fucking tripping?
Was this one also the one that was in the ground?
What
Oh
This is nice
So that would be a good one
To open den with little no tree and ground cover
What
Why isn't let me know tree and ground cover. It's right near some trees that one's good. That's a good choice
I don't really believe oh
Maybe there's more trees that are gonna appear because the other one didn't have trees
How's the rent and amenities exactly those are important things to consider
I
It's gonna pass
I wish I would like have an icon above showing where they actually were
Is it over here?
This one. Yes, it was over here. It was over here. I bet this one's also gonna mention like ground cover shit
What a den
It doesn't have any ground cover
I like this one because it's like it's a cute little place for the pups to play and it's a great view
You can see the sunrise in the morning
You know, I'll howl with you baby boob
There's a washer giant unit. I know that's very important
Um, so that means the other one's all the way over there
I
Okay, let's
Okay, I have to run
I'm tired
I'm probably gonna fucking pass out from exhaustion
I just want to go to those last one just to see what the coverage is
Should I deal with a cougar than an eagle?
I don't know
Because I feel like like with an eagle I could just like scare it off
Um, whereas with the cougar I'd probably have to fucking fight it off
I like this one because it's by the water, you know, very beautiful lake side. I mean riverside
I bet it's gonna say that's open
Where is it? Where is it?
I don't want to go so fast
What the fuck is it?
Am I tripping?
I'm like right on top of it, but I don't see it
Out here it is
See this is a fancy fucking looking den
What it done
More ground cover. You know what? I'm going with this one because it's cool
You can go pick up your pumpkin dip. That's true
Um, what should we call it?
Snaggle rock, although it's a not that what should we call it? This is a cool ass den
This music is nice
Epic not done. No! Nottingham den? There's gonna be children living here. Cool ass den. That's a pretty cool
But would it be like den den? Like would it add another den at the end?
Cool ass den
I can't believe I birthed like that earlier. I'm still it's terrifying me
I
Tying the knot I like pup max
Pup pump max
The pup maxing den
Oh, they'll be arriving soon. We're gonna have babies
It's my birthday. Wow
Uh, age perks review the available age perks for your next year of life decide if you want to advance in age
If so select three perks in advance
Note that only one new years of age works active at the time. They don't come in at your lifetime. Okay
Probably never been to your birthday too means you've survived another year as a wild wolf. I'm three years old about to have babies
That's not bad. Sometimes good. Sometimes not review your choices and decide if you want to stay advanced or stay as I am
So I can just stay as my age. How does that work?
So
I can get more stamina
Be more damage or in tracking paying competitors. I can be a fun parent
Pups never get tired of socializing
More likely to have a large litter of pups sick pups are more likely to the competitor. What the fuck? I want that
It's called clout. I want some clout. I want out. I want clout
So I can pick three
I don't really care about that. Um, I'll do these
What can I
Stay my age
I gotta advance age three
Advance vigil these new perks for the coming year. You cannot go back to your younger self. Yeah, that's fine
Oh
After nine weeks of gestation
They look just like me. If your pups are born and dead blind and deaf
They weigh one pound each your pups may remain in the den for several weeks eating sleeping pepper. We do it out
Three weeks. They first emerged in the den in the sunlight. They're dark brown now a few weeks of puppy coats will end up
Oh, okay. Why should we name though? I have babies. Look how cute my babies are
Blimey stop trying to chew my fucking headphones
You're ruining the moment
Wait, I could just name them after my hold on. I'm naming them after my cats
Oh my god, there's really two girls and a boy
Bro
I'm gonna cry
Oh
Shapa shabu shabu shubu
It's literally two girls and a boy. Oh, it's boomy rain and fia. Oh wait, but if my pets die
I'm gonna be very upset if if I have to keep these puppies alive at all fucking costs guys
We're going to do it I can tell them to come with me to come here go home. Oh, okay
Now four weeks old your pups are too big for the den as they spend their days playing outdoors socializing them playful emotes
Get my pack if they're playful if they're hungry feed them straight for them go find them and carry them back
Pups mostly eat me regurgitated by you and your mate
What I'm about to
Baby bird this shit into your mouth. You must protect them from predators
You may see a wolf pup is an easy target keeping your pups until they weigh 15 pounds
Cool
Especially as they're both your pups
Go find food eat it and then regurgitate it
And you go hunting wolf to tell your pups to stay in the den usually stay there like on but affinity is low
Like to come out before you're turned. Oh, okay
Oh god, and I still have to maintain the fucking hiss the thing
Your fee is oh, oh my god, little fia
Hi fia
Oh my god, it's my baby
Sorry, I didn't mean to bump you. Oh my god, look at reina
Hi guys, what's up? How's it going? Where's boomie?
The fuck where the hell is my mate?
Oh
Boomie the big boy. He's darker. What the hell?
Oh my god, and reina has blue eyes
Wait, do they all blue eyes?
I forget if wolf puppies have blue eyes when they're born. Oh, there he is
Oh my god, boomie. You're so cute. Oh, can I can I play with you?
Oh, I just regurgitated for you. Well enjoy. Would you guys like some food?
Yeah, eat that
Guys make sure you eat eat my eat my puke, please
Um, how do I
Try this do you like playful?
I am stuck walking on my child
Use emotes, that's what I'm trying to do
Pop cam, okay
Got the got the pop cam. Oh, but pop maxing done
Does that do anything for them? Is that am I socializing?
Oh
We're having a great time. Look at my babies. Where did my husband go?
Did he go did he go get food or
All right
Wait, can I go in the den because you couldn't do that before
Can you go in there?
What the fuck I can just hang out in here
I didn't can I go out please my pops still here. I'm like, I hope nothing comes and tries to fucking attack them
You know pups are in the way. Yeah. Yeah, okay
um
You guys are good. So have you guys go in there?
I wish there was a puppy one
voice
Do I tell the pups to go in
Go home
Go in the den
Get in the freaking den
Ruff get in there
Your bats get in there
Mama needs to go piss everywhere
Your world looks like a Tibetan sand fox. Oh, yeah, you're right
Goofy
Um, I don't know what the circle in the hex means
Uh, I'm actually pretty good. I guess I could go preemptively
Do stuff where where'd hubby go? Oh
um, I'm gonna talk to you
And tell you to stay
Okay, he doesn't seem that bothered by it so
Did you
Did you go throw up over there? Why is there?
We're gurgitated meat all the way over there. All right. Well
All right, I gotta go on a piss adventure
I'm gonna go renew that one all the way over there and pee on the way
I gotta go make sure that the territory is good. Is he coming with me?
Okay, he's not good. I just wanted to make sure someone's home with the puppies
We are the piss adventurers
Toggle my neat meets name tag, okay, I could see the binautical he is at home
Pissing time
My pups will survive
I'm gonna go steal some territory
Uh
I feel like I could actually steal the sum till our side
In a perfect world, I would have the corner
But me thinks that will not happen
Then nearby
Is the same one as before
Can I move them to another den
I feel like it. Can I just like do that?
Are these the same dens as before or is this one up here? What the hell? Yeah, it's okay
It's my tag. Wow. Are you an agamist wolf today? Yeah, I'm just I'm just by myself. I'm hanging out
You
What the fuck I thought that was like smoke coming out of the ground for some reason
This
It's renewing on the way, you know, you know how we do we just renew
Going to fuck up the Lamar pack
I don't even know what I'm supposed to fucking do though because like
Like how long is it take for them to grow up? Oh shit. Am I the wrong way?
Oh god, here we go
Jump
I don't have a bubble. It's fine. Look at my little tail. Wee. It's propelling me forward
Let me get the hair
Oh, oh my god, I'm too fast. I need to back up
Yes time
I bet the game would also look a lot different because I'm like, oh, there's no tree cover
But I bet when it's on max graphics. It actually looks okay
How's everyone doing chat just wolfing around we're wolfing out tonight
I know might be boring because I'm playing wolf running simulator, but I'm actually enjoying myself
I'm so like focused. I'm just like, yeah, this is some good stuff
Collectible object
What
Like it
I can't pick it up
Why do I have a fucking oil lamp I don't need this shit
Leave that there
What am I gonna do with that
Making pens cursing the day someone thought it'd be funny to get a nail on a tree
Oh
What do you what I don't know what did you do for work? So that would be a thing
I
Depth of the game with territories and stuff is nuts. I know
Yeah, if you fall asleep, that's fine
It's fall asleep to me happen
My butt is going numb though
Cool means that's all walk through I'm gonna snag these hexes on over here by the red Lamar pack
Okay, it seems like they don't fade as much when you finally make your den
Like you can kind of
Keep it cool
Period, yep, I'm stealing this shit, bro. I'm stealing it
It's a hobby for what oh
Yes, I remember I was like watching a bunch of tiktoks of that before
And I just wanted to learn how to do it. So I went to this local like woodworking shop
I'm like, hey, you guys do this and they're like no and I'm like, oh, okay
That's too bad. I'm gonna piss one more time
Okay, I don't know why I thought I needed to piss again
I wonder if you two bull demonetizes because I'm just like the ai is this gonna be talking about piss the entire time
Perfect perfect rock to piss on
No, I didn't do anything. All right, I guess I just gotta run around in here some more then I'll take it over
Although what I really should be doing I really should be focusing on the ones in the corner
So I might go and do that check on the pops and go do the ones in the corner
Grab some food on the way. You know, you know what I'm saying
Yeah, I'll just I'm so tempted to snag these two though. They're just like they're just there for the taking
Look at those fucking rocks. Can I kill this bird? No
Hope my puppies are okay
Oh, nope. I'm back in my territory
There we go
I'm getting the let's go back. I won't worry about that random
Although but the purples are gonna probably take it
It's mine
Because it's cut off from their territory, so it doesn't even fucking matter
because it's so they sandwiched in between me and
Yeah
We're doing strats get some macaques for the pups
Get some maracas
I'm gonna go towards the wolf so
Where Jesus I have to go all the way this fucking hill it's gonna take me forever to get back up
Yeah, I know the fucking purple wolves are like give us this shit. We want this area. Oh perfect. Okay
What the hell
I'm I'm peeing out of my back. I'm a very talented bunny
You can do many things. What the fuck this should be like a dense site. Are you kidding me?
Oh, whoa, I'm gonna pee up here
This is pretty
Look at this. You told me this isn't a dense site. It'd be a shitty dense site
But there's a tree growing on this rock. I almost got stuck in it. That would have been bad
I am pissing everywhere pissing everywhere. I'm pissing everywhere. No one can stop me
Pissing out my back
I'm sliding down this rock
What says there's a den nearby this is weird
I don't want to keep going this way
I'm gonna pee next to this tree
Lion king odd den it really is though
Really was a lion king odd den
I can't climb up there
I don't know what else I have to fucking do to take over this hex
There we go finally that took a long time
Too soon
Fuck you. All right, let's go check on the babies
See how the the kittens are doing. I mean the puppies
Oh, maybe it's just showing me mine
Yeah, my den is down here. Wee
I wonder if I follow this river. It'll probably leave me right to it
What the fuck is happening here?
Yeah, okay
I haven't run into any like wildlife
I
Wish I could run in pee faster. I accidentally keep moving
There we go
Pretty sure if I run down this. Oh, can I drink?
Yeah, drinking doesn't really do anything
I don't need to drink water I'm a wolf. What the fuck, okay
I literally bet if I follow this river it will take me straight back to the thing. No, it won't what the fuck
Okay, I should probably grab food on the way
Mom, can you give McDonald's McDonald's a hoe?
It's just like a kids cuisine
Everything the piss touches is yours
I
Also how oh perfect what's that over there? Hope they didn't hear me
It's gonna be a bitch to chase them though. I need to chase them in the direction of my stuff
Slide down this hill with my tail propelling me
Oh
No, I'm chasing them in the red territory
I meant to chase them in a different territory if I circle them to go this way
Heard them heard them go
Can I please bite one of you?
Like
It's annoying because it locks me on one and I'm like I try to unlock
I'll just piss one at it
Let's see
Perfect like run them into my story. I'm trying to direct them
towards the
Den
I can like kind of drive them closer
All right, I'm pressing a different button as if I'm locking on just like in elden ring or lice p
See all right, I'm supposed to in the middle. That's fine
I
Run no, I'm going the wrong direction now. Oh, whatever
Wolf souls man, that'd be so fucking sick if you could just be a wolf with a sword walking around
Sorry, I'm cutting my little howl off
Gumi what are you doing you play with your toy?
I
What's up boomi, I don't know if you guys can hear him. He's like
I'm peeing out of the wrong leg, but it's fine
Play
That's a good point
Oh
Is that a hair I couldn't see it. It's probably hair
I
Think a little bites easier
Should play a for what is that about like apes?
Let me guess it's about apes
Play the human not good with material especially if you know his purpose
I kind of like I I like I like reading a lot of the lore for elden ring and
to be honest
Blades path was one of the most
Or blithe I keep pronouncing his name not the correct way. Blithe's path was the most interesting to me
Just like struggle
I wish I followed it
But I was because I like I initially went was going for the Ronnie ending, but then I
Didn't stick with it. Do I have any like food around here?
It's bison I can't take down a fucking bison
Well came back empty-handed
I did have a bite, but I also need to sleep
So we're going back to the den
Kind of tragic doesn't want to lose me the way it was. Yeah
Den nearby is it my own?
Is it my own den that's nearby?
Oh
Wait
I didn't see them there
I
Like how they hop
Come on
I'm so close to your ass
I must ran into a tree I got tired some exhausted. All right. Let's just head back
Where's my family?
Oh perfect, I'm happy I can see them because that makes it a lot easier for me
She's sick to part two two for the wool quest stream. I don't know
Maybe I don't know if you guys like women watch you play this
I'm so tired. I can't run
Hi, is it time to sleep? Oh fia. What are you doing out here?
This is definitely a fia thing to do. Although it is also a boomy thing to do
I'm gonna pee right next to the den
I
What are you doing lady
She's just hanging out because
Okay, like I don't know how to like play with them. Do I just like play about
Are she acting like she's dead? Is that how she sleeps? It's funny because that's how fia sleeps though
No food
Ma'am, can you wake up? I didn't mean to throw up but okay. I'm trying to pick her up
Can I go in there? No
What are you doing lady get in there it's time to sleep get on in there bud
Can I go in there too please oh look we're all hanging
Why am I dreaming of a fucking fire Jesus
I would watch you paint dry. I would watch you watch paint dry
If you don't watch she's serving so it came from your sir
Why do I only have one pup in here? Where are my other puppies?
Oh, it's pretty outside
Cowell
Oh my god the babies
All right seems like we're good looks like everybody's kind of just like filled their hexes
I think it's time we expand to the corner
I'm gonna sleep one more time
It's my exhaustion is up what the fuck is this puppy doing over here?
I
Raina has fallen ill spending time with them are pooser odds. What the fuck
Why are you ill?
I gotta eat more before I can regurgitate
No, no you don't get to wait. How do I
Okay, fiat get over here. I'm here. I don't want to regurgitate. I'm trying to pick you up
What what are these puppies doing
Bumi get over here
Come here come here, dude
Oh
I don't trust shit
Hang out here
Where the fuck the binautical go oh she has a fucking stick
Boby come back
You better oh my god
These are literally like this is literally real life except Raina isn't sick, but she's old
Um
How am I supposed to quest feed your pups until they weigh 15 pounds where they go. Oh my god
Get back
Go
You want to play
I don't really know if that's what I'm supposed to do
Keeping an eye on Raina so fucking nothing takes her
He's digging that's that's a boomy thing
Can you guys get a little bit closer to the den please do you do you mind?
You're making me anxious
I would appreciate it if we move we moved if we moved
Back to the den
Come on boomy
Oh wait, I forget I can tell you guys to do shit
I'll come in there with you. I don't know where your dad went. We're all spending time together. Look at us
We're hanging out
This is some good family bonding time
What else do I have in my snack box? There's a lot of like sweet stuff in here. I kind of want something more savory
I
That's a coffee bar
What is this blueberry?
I can't wishing that there's a lot of like french inspired korean stuff in here
I guess they really like the french aesthetic like should be having this with tea
Oh chewy chocolate chip cookie
Family bonding you want to be the den with me
You want to be part of my I'm bringing sexy pack and then
How do I know how much they weigh?
Wait a second
Hmm
Boomy's a big boy if you're a small girl everything is a little bit smaller
Fleece mild
Like fullness
Why is my nautical non the den he's going to go get food. Oh my god, look at them
Did you bring back food for them
You
Can you go get our son?
I guess all the way over there
What the children where are you going?
Get back go back
It seems like rain is feeling better
Oh, all right guys, um my nautical can you can you keep an eye on them?
You're so cute though, it's so funny how much they have the personalities of my actual fucking cats. Oh
Oh
Adorable
That's our territory. Oh, it's okay
Can't tell if we lost anything
I don't raina seems like she's doing good
Raina oh my god
It's funny because raina sometimes does this thing where I'll be like give me belly
And she'll roll over into her belly and she lets me pet her belly. This is adorable. I'm having the best time of my life right now
Live vicariously
Come here though. I'm gonna bring you closer to the den
Where's boomie go get boomie. He's just like all the way over there
Well, this is great
All right, um, what am I sniffing the fuck?
I am going to tell people to go home
Get in the den
Can I interact with you are you gonna I think he just automatically stays I don't really know
I can I tell him to come with me?
Oh, I think that tells him to get come with me. Oh, aren't you funny? Oh anonymous tip for dollars and 20 cents
Gimme belly does this work? No, it doesn't nice try though. Nice try though. All right, let's go
We're going to take over the corner
Puppy should be fine, I hope please don't wander off and get eaten by stuff
I
Need to find smells
The binautical mule deer
All right, we're going up I want to go down
A lot of stuff is coming up from here anyways. Oh, are they just here? No two hours ago
Oh
Oh my god, I'm still going. How do I just like randomly go the wrong way?
I don't understand it
Okay, let's take this shit over boy. There it is
I'm gonna get some food on the way. How perfect is that?
Yeah, I'm gonna try to run into the rock. I need a pause. Yeah, because it's right here
Not doing anything
Street lights are on get a little ass to the tent
I think you came to see this for the super
I'm sorry. It's a fucking piss here
All right, well still got to find food because hungry as fuck
Over there, okay
See we can cut them off
Oh
Where they go
No, that's hair where the fuck did I but I accidentally run them off for my stupid
Well, it's like coyote. I really don't care about that
Well, the fuck that those deer just go
Did I lose them amongst the tree trunks? Because I am apt to do that
Oh
What the heck? The scent just disappeared
The hell where the fuck it was just said 15 minutes ago, then it fucking disappeared. Are you serious?
Bruh
I'm getting tired of hunting for food
25 minutes ago am I going the opposite direction? Nope. Yep. It looks like they meant to go this way
I didn't get super smell where you could do that
Okay, so they were right over here
Yeah, we're gonna hunt another pack fucking territory
The fuck
I'm losing the dough to the pronghorn
Oh my god, please. I'm just I just want to eat
Oh perfect
No, get the one closer
Come on
Bring her down bring her down super smell also includes bad smells. That's a good point
But like I always wondered like why a dog doesn't recognize like bad smells or like
Because like cats will react to bad smells, but I've never seen like dogs really react to bad smells. I don't know
Actually, no, they probably like huff
Like I'll just sink it to the ground. Okay. Oh, I think we're good
I want that fucking thing though
I
Want to change I feel like we have to like run across it
I'm really pissed in this area so many fucking times
Finally
It's way too long
And if we get any food on the way then we'll grab some
Um
My commentary is leaving me I'm like losing the yappage because I'm just so focused and enjoying myself
Everything is different smells that are bad bad usually means danger to animals. That's a good point
I
Live in my work wolf girl dreams right now
Wait name tags are on I wonder where the where are the baby so I can't I say them
As long as we're having a good time she be she's immersed because
I remember
on time
I was talking to
My dad was like, how do you want your steak and I said like rare because I like rare steak or like medium
um
And
It was like a lot pinker like he accidentally didn't let he like not like undercooked it
But just like it was rarer than I thought it was going to be or the fuck is it in
Where's that dad bro
I just want to get to my puppies
Can't am I blind?
Is it up here?
Oh my god, um
And it like was really pink and oh they came out. Oh look at them. Oh you hungry eat some food
I didn't mean to pick you up
Oh my god
Enjoy
And it was I can't get it even I'm so focused on the game and sleepy that I didn't even really might even telling the story
And it was a little bit red that was like bloody and I was just like
Oh rena sharing
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to pick you up
Come on
And I'm like I gotta do this one thing
And um
My dad's like, oh you should be fine because I was just like I think it's too bloody like it looks like there's a blood clot in it
He's like it doesn't matter, you know, because you're a wolf and I'm like what he's like
Yeah, because like don't you like being a wolf and stuff. I'm like dad
If Adam is happy being a wolf that ought to be and it's funny because when my parents like when I first started
To V2 my parents are like, why didn't you pick a wolf? I'm like because everybody's a fucking wolf and then I picked a cat
And then everybody's a fucking cat. So I don't know what the fuck I was talking about and now I'm a bunny
And now everybody's a bunny
Oh
I'm like 2.0. Should I just like change my animal 3.0
Dad knows what it up
Feels a little weird, man
All right
Oh my god, hi boomie. Oh my god, the real life boomie. It's him
Hi, Sean
Can you get in the bed if you're gonna hang out up here?
3.0, she's an alligator. I was like debating whether or not to be like a reptile
Does that mean they're full? I don't really
It's really funny because they're very close to their actual colors. The boomie is not a black cat. So that's
Speaking of boomie, where the fuck did he go? Oh, he's with he's with uh his dad
Boomi is chewing on the box that
Who came in?
All right, well I'm gonna pass the fuck out later. Don't get eaten by something, please
I
Like we should I should have made them sleep in the den
Wake up wake up
Where's boomie where's boomie
Where's boomie?
Okay, Jesus you scared me son
Would you like some food?
Enjoy kiddos
By by nautical you're not really regurgitating enough in my opinion
No, are you wagging his tail at them?
Boomi's the wild child. Boomi is the wild child. He's the wild child and then he's he's always smacking feet in the face right now
Which is funny because they're fighting in the game or they're playing in the game and now they're they're playing
They're literally right next to me and reina's doing reina always does her own thing. She's like, oh, she's like she's a cool cat
Um, I'm picking up though reina. Well
Moving too fast come here child
Why does it sound like something from the princess bride?
Where are the children? Oh my god
What are you doing all the way over here?
Yeah, does he have a stick in his mouth? Oh, he's a bone
Oh
Oh, he's a bone
How long does it take for them to get that big?
Oh my god, this is gonna take fucking forever
They're only at seven pounds
How high is the affinity?
Oh my god
Sorry, I didn't mean to pee right in front of you. He didn't have to whine like a baby about it
Well, what are you actually doing? I'm talking to him
Right now. Um, okay. I have to go
I'm gonna go do that right now. Uh, actually before I do that
Get in there
Yeah, you too dad
Is there any
Yeah, you you're getting there
All right
What there's a fucking bear
Why is it saying there's a grizzly?
I don't see a fucking grizzly
What's with the grizzly thing where is said grizzly?
Where is it
Where's the fucking grizzly I'm gonna end its life. I will literally kill it
Oh, what the fuck
You no, you're not killing fucking fear
Get the fuck out of here. I'm so happy I didn't leave because I almost did no stay away from fear
Can I can I grab fear
Oh
Cool, okay fear come here Jesus Christ
Get in there
Go go go go lay down
You better fucking get in there. Are you okay? Are you good?
Are you okay?
Jesus Christ
Okay, I'm gonna nap first. That was terrifying. I was actually like scared
I'm dreaming of rabbits
My yeah, I was right. I was ready to kill I was gonna
Fuck that bear up. Don't even don't even don't even mess with me, dude
There's a fuck what is outside?
What is
No, go back in go home get back in there
Where is is there another wolf I don't
Know
Oh, okay, I guess by nautical you are amazing
I think by nautical uh scared him off. So that's cool. Um nice, okay
I'm gonna go piss over here
Okay
Sorry, I have to make sure I'm in the right orientation
I'm not like, oh, I need to go north. I'm like, oh, I must point my arrow in the right way
Otherwise bad things will happen
So that boosted a bunch no, I think I'm not oh, yeah now I'm in the right one
Rogue ass wolves be on uncle put in some work there. Honestly props to by nautical. I'm I'm very impressed with him
I'm not gonna bother to go all the way over there for that. Um
I'm gonna go down down the river that's not down the river
To see if I can find some food in the corner
One of the puppies is like super low
I think it's
Damn rena is still sick rena may not make it
Oh
Not good. She's at 20 life right now. Jesus. Fuck. I didn't mean to go that way
Why is there like no
You know, I must I'm not even gonna focus on taking over corners. I might just focus on trying to fucking find food
That way
Oh
Come on
Get it get it
I
Let that not fuck you up
There we go
Almost there almost got you come here come here
You're almost dead
You're mine
Oh
No, I'm out of stamina
But so are you
You better oh my god, let's wait till I get my stamina back
Stop trying to fight back just fucking die
Actually, I can take a little piece of meat
I ate that meat chunk because I can probably bring a meat chunk back to what's his face
Or maybe not I guess I I guess I can't
I'm eating the deer's ass
Okay
I
Might as well just take this fucking square while I'm at it
My nautical getting a wind and dying while I was trying to I don't know if it's gonna work out
At least I killed that like right next to our stuff
Oh, they might show up that would suck if they did
So
Because they are fairly close
Oh, okay
Oh my god, you go I need to go take care of rena
I'm just gonna pee fucking everywhere
Oh wait
How am I still not technically in here there we go
Oh damn it whatever all right
I think with the dot in the square it means you can never like
Um, I'll lose that square which is are the hexagon which is nice
Yeah, it's a lot easier to maintain the hexagons now now that when you actually have a den in place and like a
Tree you don't have to do as much
To like maintain it except to run around every once in a while
Wolf wasn't pissing she's squared on command. Oh my god
All right, where's again I lose track of where the fucking den is
Hello
Oh
Wait, I shouldn't be able to see them from here. Okay, perfect
Hey guys, I got some food for you. How you doing rena? I didn't mean to go in there. I wasn't even close to being in there
What the fuck is that?
That creepy ass power where's boomie
Oh, no, I'm not trying to go in there, please
Now once you go back and eat where's boomie where's boomie
Where's boomie?
He's all the way over there
Come eat your food kid
This is so stupid, how did rena even get sick?
Oh my back
So he's where's boomie and how's boomie? Yeah
Cool
I guess we can we can play and hang out
Oh, he just like woke up
Oh
Reina come out and play
She's even lower than before. Oh, no
She's at 13 percent
No, poor old they don't know if reina's gonna make it. I'm generally gonna cry
It's gonna be like rena died in the night. She didn't make it. Can I wake up, please?
Oh, thank god, look at it. That's actually literally how she'll sleep on me though
And I come out and it's like fia and boomie are dead
I'll be like what?
Here you go. I didn't mean to pick you up
Reina come eat
No, what I did was nowhere near there, please
Oh
He's so cute
There you go eat that
Nice cool
You'll fee you want to play you want to you want to you want to sniff
Can I sniff her?
Can I can I do that with
I don't really think it can
You know how well
We stay winning
Wait, I like how it said reina's recovered what she's
Okay, she's just recovering I suppose booby is a fat dude
If they need to use a hundred percent we could move to a new den but we're fine really
What's up for you oh you so cute girly pop
The binautical is just hanging out I suppose what the hell is reina walking weird
Okay, let me see
Okay, let's say they thought they took that square over. Oh my god blue has taken the whole bottom. Holy crap
Damn blue
I
Think I'm gonna go for that
Um carcass real quick
So I'm gonna tell them to
Roof
Get back, okay, he just fucking brought them over like yeah, I could get back in there
You're back in there
Go on okay, I'm gonna go to that carcass if it's not taken over by stuff
Yeah, I don't really need like you know, uh the binautical can kind of just
Can kind of just like hang out stay home be a little stay at home dad
I should have brought that to him. I don't think he'll eat stuff that I bring him though unless it's a maybe if it's a meat chunk
We'll try it
Can't smell the carcass so I don't even know if it's around anymore
But there's me a fucking grizzly at it
I feel like I'm playing like mine survival minecraft except its wolves and it's nothing like this. Oh, it's just a coyote
Not pee real quick squirtin
Where's the uh, what the hell? Oh, that's right. I forgot it was in their territory
I can't wait for the velar minecraft server. Yeah, it would be goofy. I'm not good at minecraft at all
Props are going to be bigger more depends on the standard in a way as long as pack of any side
But remember I suppose my venture out when finny drops too low
And it's a fleet infestation worse since props will be more likely to leave the den as affinity drops keeping my small
Okay, pack affinity
I can't that's so small
This was at one point they'll be tempted to leave the den
But like how
Is if it gets that below I suppose if it gets that okay. Yeah, because I'm like a hundred
It's my carcass gone bro. I'm about to pee on this fucking marker. I don't even give a shit
But you're fucking you
Um
Wonder if I should though diagonal. Yeah, fuck it. We ball
Seems like everybody's fine
I'll try to find some food on the way
Oh, I swear to god, I didn't go that way, but okay go off
Take some territory, but she was using us by nautical
Make sure the long streams you be good night. Yeah, of course. I'm just I'm just hanging out. I'm just having a good time
But uh, I'm happy you enjoyed
I'm like honestly really tempted just to keep playing until I beat this
Oh, it's grizzly fuck
Grizzly better not be going near my babies or we're not gonna have a good time
What's that?
Is that
Is that an elk
Maybe I can run it to the edge of the map. Yeah
Fuck oh shit
Damn it. Okay. Well, I'm out of here
Hey, where's your scent markers so I can fucking piss on it
Is that it over there? Yeah, this I'm gonna go piss on your fucking scent marker, dude
Cause I'm a bad bitch. Oh, I can't mark territory to fight
I'm not trying to mark I'm trying to fucking kill this dude
Damn it
Why I'm like don't know what's going on with my camera. I like can't do anything
What the fuck did he go like he's grabbing me before I fucking can
Like I'm not even oh
This is okay. This is a really dumb mechanic because
It's not letting me like turn the fucking face. Oh, I didn't mean to do that
Cause like I'm biting him first
It's it's like fucking up my camera
And I don't know why it's doing that
Okay, apparently he is dead. He got scared
All right. Um, well, I'm gonna go fucking piss in a spot
Fucking bitch
She's getting monged this fight, you know, but I don't I didn't need him
It's really just it's literally like I can't
The game camera like it resets your camera and it fucks with your camera so I can't turn
I want to take this whole bottom corner it's gonna be mine
I
Definitely need to find something to eat though a lot of grizzlies and cougars. I don't know why I smell a skull
They're howling I'm gonna how
There's a lot of fucking grizzlies around the home
I
This way towards the
Grizzly smell and other smells the smelly smell that smelly
What are my other things looking like? I don't know my hexes are pretty okay
I
Want to fight we take the corner
Grizzly bear, okay
I was trying to find the prawn horn
My house still smells like burnt popcorn
It's definitely down here gotta keep falling the
The fuck did they turn around? Oh, they went this way
I fucking backtracked the sons of bitches. Oh, they're there
I'm locking on and isn't working
Why isn't it my lock on working?
Am I too far away? No, it's just oh, I love it. I love it
Can I not target lock on if I'm like injured or some shit?
Here I go
Because I had free cam on it doesn't let you fucking oh, okay
Perfect
They don't want to run off the cliff
Oh, perfect. I'm killing you all right here. Oh, damn it. They ran around me
Cool
Let's see if I can take a piece of meat off for husband
Oh, I can perfect drop that save that for him
All right, I'll do a little how
I'm burning popcorn now my house is still I'm just trying to pick it up
Um, I don't even know why it does it's been days
It seems like there's always prawn horn in that little area
I'm a bad bitch. You can't kill me
I come home my family's massacre like fucking you she honk land style
It's like ram the mass wolves
Run towards the moon. I am going the wrong way
Excuse me
Give me a second. I need to get my story straight. My friends are sorry the little shaking noise sounded like that song
Hey, then the empire's staying in love. She is waiting for me. That's to cross the ball
Oh
Isn't it someone in the beginning of that asking minus
Okay, I saw the meat in the mouth. I was like the extra limit
What the fuck is happening?
I
Where's the den?
Oh my god
Sometimes it's like it's hidden by my scent marker thing and the whatever so it's not showing me where the den is
I guess I just go towards that marker since technically I fucking pissed there. Can I follow it?
I think not
Perhaps I guess I can maybe it is good that I like fucking pissed on it
Oh, it actually is a good idea that I pissed on it
Honey I brought you some food
Enjoy
Are you gonna eat it? Oh, he's eating it. Oh my god. I'm such a good wife. I'm not going in there. Jesus
Get out
No, okay, if I'm even near that arrow it wants to fucking do it. Why do their names keep getting turned off? I don't understand
Here you go
Eat up children
Boomi you must be fed child. I'm going too fast
Okay, what are there? Oh my god, this is literally going to take forever for them to grow up
Okay, well
I'm going to sleep now. It won't let me in the fucking den. Are you serious?
It sounds like princess bride music
I pissed on her house
It's time to eat
Please don't let anything kill our puppies. Well, I'm out there. I will freak out so bad
By nautical if more of our children dies, I blame it on you
Okay
It's like kimchi flavored seaweed. Oh, I got two of the puppies in here with me. Where's the third one?
Where's the third one?
Okay, Boomi's just out there. That's fine. That's okay
Let's see. Where are we at?
Our set marks are good. I'm gonna piss here
Well, I'm gonna howl here
I
I'm normal. Can you come back here eat?
Am I how is our affinity 98? Okay, we're good
What where's
Oh, Fia's fusing to Jen come here Fia
Yeah, I'm gonna give you food right now
You batch of pups in the oven yet? I have to wait for these ones to grow up
Then I'll start start auctioning off names to the highest bidder
All right, I'll watch the pups while by nautical
Does
Whatever he's doing, uh, I wish I could see him on the map
He's not that far away actually
I wonder
What is he doing over there? He's literally just like standing
All right, well I am going to
Roll excitedly
Oh
Aren't you adorable my boomy? Oh, he loves it
All my children
I'm so I'm kind of happy I named them after my god
I think it makes me try harder
Okay, what is this thing it's like
I'm scared. Oh, what it smells like. Okay, I should have smelled that
Oh, it smells really good actually smells like oh
Oh, it's a seaweed
Oh, that's so good
It's like kimchi spicy seaweed
I don't even want to eat this because this would be so good
Oh
It's like sweet and spicy I'm gonna actually use this I'm gonna make some rice and some tuna
And do what I did before and then sprinkle this on top. That's gonna taste so fucking bomb
Wow, I'm really surprised how good this tastes
You like generally I hate seaweed snacks and this is delicious
Oh, yeah, it's showing that you could should have can roll it up with rice and stuff
Well, because I have this giant box of Korean snacks. Yes, every everything's gonna be a snack deep dive
What oh my god, she wandered away
Oh, no, oh, no, no, no, no, no, this is not it right now. Oh, no
I found my last pup did I I don't think I did
Wow
The fuck out of here
Okay, at least the pup went back I'm just trying to enjoy my snacks. Can you leave please?
At least you're not doing a lot of damage to me
Ow, I think if I get them halfway then they
Come back here. Yeah, bitch
Okay, um, are they all in there can I please
Okay, fuck they're all in here good. Oh, thank god
Praise the Lord they're all alive. They're all doing wonderful
I don't know where the fuck the binautical always right there. Hey, you got food for them
Oh my god, that's adorable
It was like the worst fucking
Combination it's like a pup's just not wandered off. Oh, uh, by the way, you're also under a cougar attack. I'm like, what the fuck?
Ah
You guys just you guys just hanging out
I'm gonna pick you up. I just like fucking
Are you guys growling at each other?
All right playing with a stick that's why you guys want some of that you hungry
I need to stop eating this it's so tasty
You
Right, what's the other thing at
I might go across I'm thinking about going across taking that purple for myself because it's weak
Yeah, go grab me. I realize if I say go home, he will go and grab the puppy, which is nice
What's our affinity looking like 100% cool
Oh
God and this is on easy mode
All right, let's do it pissing
Yeah, buddy
That's gonna take me a while to run over there
Should have asked him to come with me, but it's fine
Um, I don't know
It's just one I probably get it
Come on. Oh trying to fucking get me with the trees get you at the trees. How about that?
Buckmeal deer don't look like a buckmeal deer ow
Oh, I can see a little minor injury
Die
Grab some meat
Sick
We did it
No, the fucking crows are here
Oh, excuse me boomie. What are you doing sir? He's back up. Thank you
All right, I'll take this with me I'm gonna do a little howl
Oh, you can't do that if they're mouthful facts
This again, I need to see hard. Oh god everything probably just be attacked every five seconds
Okay, I have it in my mouth and then we're gonna go
So kind of just why are there reds nearby weird
They second pee with my mouthful
All right, that stuff is actually not agreeing with my stomach tastes is so good, but now my tummy hurts
All right, perfect. I'm actually realizing that I only goes out when you enter a new hexagon
Like I noticed that earlier, but I'm just I'm saying it out loud
Some nice ratings. Thank you
So close
Everybody's howling in these parts what's going on
Um
I'm about to take over bitches
I think is that the stunt marker because I'm pretty sure I did the stunt marker over here. Well, what I'm gonna do right now
Uh
Uh-huh purple is wavering fleas
Where pups stay in the den the faster if you please so they stay outside use the dens for shelter or safety for predators
Puppies are what likely to leave the den as flea load increases
keeping out of the blue point in the pack affinity meter
Marks the point your pups will be tempted to leave the den. Oh, okay. Oh, that's a pointer. That's so weird
I
Can't do that with my mouth full there we go
Cool
All right might as well go back
We we got in a pretty good chunk. It's not as big. I would like a corner for ourselves like I keep saying so
I'll work on that
I'm gonna just go straight ahead. Yep
I wish there was an auto run so I don't have to fucking be doing this
I
Was thinking I'm like, you know, I don't really have a lot to say today
Usually I'm like yeah master 3000, but I think just like
I
Like shit that how how life be I'm just like I'm just tired today
And I don't I'm not yapping as much
Who's that
Oh the fox
He's hanging out. I'm not gonna kill him
Yeah, we're just hanging because have you the background
Don't have to be nothing serious, you know
Making myself fucking dizzy playing this
Game's just too intense. I know it's just too intense
Like how could I not?
Oh fleas are there random like dust doubles everywhere
Where am I?
Sometimes I like to go see if there's like anything near the oh
Can I run you guys towards the den?
Can you run that way go how okay
Oh, you knocked the meat out of my mouth. No, I have to kill one of you. Which one's a fawn
Oh
Looking for a fawn looking for a fawn. Sorry don't mind me. I'm just looking for a fawn. There's a lot of bucks in this herd
Ah, why are you guys both attacking me?
Oh do you then
Now
Oh, I didn't mean to grab you but this also works
Well
She whipped her around
I might have to come call reinforcements for this one. Oh come back
Yeah, I don't think I'll be able to fuck can't believe I dropped the meat
I'll come back to that. Oh, there's an elk is still over here
Raspberry elk herd that's cute
What the fuck oh coyotes hello
Yes some more
Cool take that to him. I'm happy I killed that nearby. I'm exhausted. I'm going the wrong way
Bring this back to the hubbin
Your health is scarily low. No, it's not if it was less if it was
Yeah, no, it's it's actually not that low. It's low, but it's like it's not that bad
You know
It's fine
I think I accidentally cut off my peeing animation. There we go. I realize sometimes I just pee too fast
I'm also exhausted. Yeah, yeah, dead nearby. It's probably mine
Oh, hi Rena. I was wondering where you've been. That's not big mama
Rena's been pretty chill today. She's been doing her own thing. Hi, you thinking of me?
I missed you, but whoa
What's the matter?
Oh, it's because boomie walked up and she saw him and she got upset. Are you okay?
No
It's just me
Boomi's not around
She's not happy
Oh, I see what's going on
Rina do I got to bring you to the vet again?
I think Rena Rena is again. She's an older cat. Um
So sometimes
She was I was kind of confused because she was acting pretty lethargic today
Um
And I was like why are she she's just like kind of hanging out by herself and I'm like what's going on here lady
and um
She sometimes gets like one of her uh her glands clogged and I think that's what's going on because
Boomi leave her alone. She doesn't feel good
Because her her booty looked weird. Can you move?
Oopsies I must maybe drop my controller dude
All right, let me see
Put that down. There you go. That's for you. It's your meat chunk
Come and get it
Come and get it proper tins
Boomi, please stop tearing up my thing
Boomi's attacking my foot rest
Yo, Rena barked. Yeah, she's older. So like sometimes it doesn't it won't express itself
So I'm probably actually I'm gonna
Make an appointment for it can't hurt gland express. I've tried to do it myself
um
It's just it's really hard. Yeah, I could see it. She's not having a good time
It's funny because she was like fine yesterday, so I'm wondering if something happened
Why do you look so mad? She's like I don't feel good my butt hurts
All right, don't worry miss ma'am. I'll take you to the vet ASAP. So you feel right as rain
Although you're gonna hate it because you hate having your butt touched, but it is what it is
Grumpy she's like I don't like it. It's like this
If I want to be backed up every other month. Yeah, so it's such a weird thing
It's like she has plenty of fiber. She has it's just like, you know, just age
She's 14 so
He's like give me that meat chunk
Enjoy let's see how the thing is
And it's so funny that is it okay, is it weird that the game's like rain is sick
She was sick immediately and then she got better. That's so weird. I'm sorry. That's just weird to me
That's weird the game's telling me that my own cat's sick
I didn't mean to lock on a boomy
There you go
I
Said she got better so we're short so we did so we write as rain
Maybe you're weird I am weird the game knows you
All right, I think I'm actually am gonna end it here
I'm wondering if I should just like I really want to finish this game now, but I want to check on rain and make sure she's good
Maybe I can put some um
I can give her
She has pain medication that I can give her so at least she'll be comfortable before I take her to the vet tomorrow
I have a really nice vet. She's honestly, uh, super close to my family. She um
Took care of fia when fia was going through her stuff
Um, and it was like she was so nice because she would literally just give us stuff. Um, like me and my current stuff are free
um
Like I had to like get medication. She's like, no, it's free and I'm like, oh because she like I was spending again like I've spent
Like eight over eight thousand dollars on getting fia better and they still don't know
They still don't know what caused her legs to stop working
They still don't know they ran so many tests cat scans all the scans MRIs
Ultra sounds they still don't know she's she's like, oh, she was perfectly fine
I don't know why this is happening. Like is she is she doing it for attention?
Cat scans but don't oh, oh, oh, oh. They're just so funny. Where did fia go?
Um, I'm missing a child
Let me go check if she's in here.
Wait, is this a save and pack info?
Oh yeah, Fiat isn't dead.
Oh, it means 10 pounds.
Okay, we're getting close.
I'm gonna save.
I have to save it as something?
Can I just save it?
Um, save it as Reina Grumpy.
Here we go.
Perfect.
It didn't even, it doesn't even work when I type with the controller.
Reina Grumpy.
Save you.
Alright.
Thank you guys for watching.
I'll let you know I didn't hit submit.
Oh, I thought that was submit thing.
Look how pretty I am.
Wow.
I look at you guys updated with how Reina is doing in feeling, but I will bring it tomorrow.
I'm gonna look through, make sure I don't miss any streamer.
Oh, what is this?
Alright, I think I called those all out.
Cool, cool, cool.
Thank you guys for your support today.
I appreciate it.
You guys are bomb.
I have to put up my fucking, whatchamacallit.
Reina, just like that in the live.
Schedule up.
I have a members, members stream tomorrow.
We're gonna do the tier list, the tag tier list.
That'll be fun.
I have to ask Strawny what she used for hers or anything.
But I'll see you guys around.
Bye.
Have a good day, stinky butt.
Bye bye.